hop
ça a dû bouger
sans que vous ne bougez y est en
espérant que les caméras marche bientôt
parce que pour le moment on ne les a pas
pour le moment la caméra qui ne se dote
pas
terrible
j'espère
que vous me voyez que ça marche et je
sais pas pour quelle raison les caméras
qu'ils votent pas
c'est terrible
ok celle de maxime a lot déjà
c'est la bonne news
simon déjà on va du coup aller sur un
échiquier de maxime on à la cam qui
s'allument
de cheveux aléatoire du ministre
à
est ce que je suis en train de réfléchir
en fait à la position je me disais fouet
sans fin ne peut pas faire des france et
4 passes cafu pour le 4-1 le pion sert à
protéger et je me demandais surtout f5
et ce qu'il veut genre tout re 1
m.aliyev 6-10 ans hayatou reprendre
cette pardon est ce qu ont fait
cavaliers fils direct et là tu sais 5 et
on va être moins bien ça ressemble à ce
qu'on appelle une attaque pas neuf et
quand le pion réponse et 5 et qu'on fait
des cinq qui avait laissé trois tours eu
en fait on va vis et le pion aux 7 qui
sera bloquée en russie ce on va
contrôler la case 5 et on va bloquer le
pion à eux et nous avec les blancs va
jouer sur le 3 contre 2 donc ça c'est
pas cool pour maxime et le pion aux 7 et
inamovible quoi on peut pas l'envoyer à
eux 5
du coup c'est ça l'idée des blancs mais
pourquoi est ce qu'il a commencé par à 4
jours si on avait fait tour eu un
fou ici et c5 disons c'était quoi le
problème
à 5 disons pour casser b5 pour avancer
et e5 maintenant
rampillon prend pions prendre ces 8
ok qu'est ce que ça change a refait à 4
si je fais quand même fou et f5
je fais quand même à 5
que je fais tout ces
8es ou cinq ans pas trop le problème en
fait
à dire en fait si on fait juste fais 5
à 5 jours pas le problème
tu as juste pas de problème pour les
noirs
aucune idée mais je vois pas de problème
à vrai dire
ne jouera pas même pour maxime
physiquement ça fait peur visuellement
c'est pas la position de max
pas vraiment
position d'ali reza est plus inquiétante
ans on va voir si on voit là la cam
d'alireza
j'essaie de décider de laisser espérer
qu'elle ce lot
après c'est un problème de calmes
sur cet échiquier je pourrais pas y
faire grand chose à la malheureusement
c'est pas moi qui m'occupe vraiment la
technique donc je vais espérer que ça
soit je voir si l'autre coin ça c'est la
table 3
ça c'est la table 2
et la table eu en fait on réussit pas la
récupérer
c'est pas de bol ce qu'on voulait
justement garder la partie d'alireza
aujourd'hui
mais je crois que le destin veut qu'on
regarde maxime
max à jouer donc on a la position de fil
rouge à en bas à droite pour le moins il
joue pas
on va se mettre un tout petit peu sur la
position de maxi on a déjà un peu vu la
position d'ali reza
alireza la position pourrait être très
dangereuse aujourd'hui un
jeu juste regarder si sur le truc en
anglais ils l'ont en fait la cam
secondes
je me prends une pub bien évidemment
et noir ont beaucoup moins
d'espacés pas s'il est perdant alors
c'est une compensation pour les morts ça
on n'en sait rien cidre à tous
les échecs c'est concret un c'est pas en
regardant 30 secondes une partie qc un
c'est pas parce qu'il regarde les
legrand suisse féminin
difficile à dire
un aveu qui a aidé sept
la can vrai mais en fait ils ont
d'autres calmes
ils ont des calmes supplémentaires en
fait chaise comme
toutes les autres cas marche en fait
j'ai d'axa j'ai accès à 6 cam est en
fait j'en ai une qui marchent pas c'est
celle là
bah il faut se faire inscrire sur 3com
fr ouais non mais bon à la cam de maxime
et c'est dommage aujourd'hui j'aurais
bien regarder la partie de farruggia à
quoi honnêtement
donc maxime donc il effaça sera quattro
abbas dans la position figure au who's
who gets attali croquer
même ce cabinet sa part de marché celle
de figure ouais c'est qu'elle marche pas
s'ils ont des cas mon grand plan et qui
n'ont pas le plan large c'est qu'elles
marchent pas eu juste ils ont accès à
beaucoup plus de caméras que moi
ce qui calcule en fait il doit calculer
tous les trucs à base d'oie à 5 aussi
une seule fois f5 tu laisses faire ces 5
pour 1 5 puis on prend tour ses huit
avec des ordres de coût différent
peut-être qu'il aurait fallu faire faut
prendre 4 d'abord mais où tu récupères
le pion c'est en force en fait c'est
hyper important dans cette position de
jouer 5 en fait si on réussit pas à
jouer cinq ce que vous expliquez tout à
l'heure ce qui va se passer si on arrive
dans un truc comme ça c'est qu'en fait
le pion il va jamais pouvoir avancer et
les blancs ils auront l'équivalent d'un
pion de plus à terme à moyen terme
ça va faire du caïd et deux tours ces
trois tours c1 et petit à petit on va
appuyer menacé et menacer ses 6 c'est
pour ça que c'est si important de très
vite faire 5 pour taper le pion des 4 et
quand il prend venir se venger sur ces 5
et du coup si on obtient ce genre de
position on va carrément être content on
viendra prendre ces cinq et on va taper
cinq et il n'y a pas de problème de
structure en réalité
donc en gros ce qu'il faut éviter c'est
que les blancs réussissent à faire c'est
ça qui a stabilisé à leurs pions c
à 5
gravement à l'idée de à 5 vs 5 c'est
quand tu joues ces cinq tons pions soit
plus soutenue par le pion b4 en fait
c'est quand tu fais ça
ben du coup le pion b4 ils défendent
plus quoi c'est ça l'idée de 1,5
du coup l'idée des blancs ça peut être à
et un peu que ça va changer la donne et
sa dame
a eu un bug frérot mais je pense qu'il
va faire 1 4 1 avec les blancs pour
essayer d'envoyer un b 5
maxime du coulage de kelkoo là vous
faussez 5 mais ça change pas grand chose
soit f5 pardon
l'autre pas vraiment aux risques qui
menacent des français car peut-être
paillage et 4 encore
mais les blancs peuvent pas développer
le cavalier il peut pas aller en c3 ou
en d2 puisque la casse les cases sont
contrôlés 6 par an à 3 et cavaliers des
deux et on va pouvoir doubler les pions
en f3 et on va être très bien
ça c'est cool pour les noirs bien
évidemment
donc du coup les blancs pas mille
options et sur ses seins qui va faire à
5 des 5,5 et on va transposer dans la
position qu'on voulait avoir on récupère
ses
c'est qu'on a ce décès g4 qui a rédigé
sa caméra fou prend 17 c'est un peu le
bordel
de toute façon les blancs dont leurs
coûts utilisons quoi ils ont tous remis
long tour c'est un arrêt dans tous les
cas on va le protéger de meillard x ou y
ses pions
en vue ni tour un bateau rhin elle coule
plus logique après 1 c'est le premier
vous que j'avais regardé tape sur le
cheval table sur 7
un nul je préfère les noirs quand même
c'est plus actifs
on ne sait prend
c'est prend des cinqs a pas une belle
tête les pions sont doublés on les prend
quand on veut on commence déjà à
pénétrer avec les noirs
le tour à trois et un coup
sa part la belle tête tour à 3 je suis
pas prête un coup mais ça pas une belle
tête
ça j'aime pas trop
décès marche ici mais à g4
g5
les f-5 manon ses protégés
ce que les quatre fûts en ligne et sur
une faiblesse ou une force ça dépend
est ce à plein de choses qu'on peut pas
dire enfin jusqu'au bien que vous
comprenez que les échecs c'est un jeu
très concret à partir d'un certain
niveau en fait on peut plus
tirer des plans sur la comète
en mode en mode ph quoi
il a joué tout après qui était le coup
le plus logique de loin
alors voir partir le fiu du fian kétou
ici ben non non
là comme je dis à tout le combat ça joue
sur le fait et ce que les blancs peuvent
planter ses cinq et on répond par cinq
pour casser ou on n'y arrive pas en fait
hein c'est tout le débat de la structure
tout se joue là dessus en fait ainsi les
blancs le temps de faire ses 5 et
stabiliser leur structure ils auront
trois vos pions et c'est une structure
de type à 9 août a réussi à amener la
majorité les blés noirs n'ont pas pu
jouer 5 s'il est noir réussissent à
faire à 5 pour mines et 1,5 pour miner
et sans prendre après option c5 ça ira
pour les noirs
ce que à 5 baies 5 tours s'est vite fait
je comprends pas trop ce que veulent les
blancs ces cinq syndicats sûrement faire
cavalier à 3 pour protéger son pion aya
papillon prend la foux prend 1,4
il veut quoi b6 pour bloquer fou prend
on prend un tour d'un jouet ça avec les
blancs
c'est peut-être pas con
option pas fou en
fou prend ici tu vois de prendre ces
cinq
n'a pas le temps de faire dépenser 4
haletant de 5 passes kf3 et la tour est
bien placé
steitz à l'idée d'en tonnes
pas de caméra chez ali raisin et la
position
ok
complet
plex complexe
je tourne un petit peu
howell korobov ça ferait pas que rob
huff gagner avec les noirs à il a joué
une irlandaise non pas du tout
je suis fait trompé par la structure en
regardant vitesse
paraissait bizarre aussi
par une prête que ça c'est dans le
groupe de maxime
well et si les mecs donne tout et qui
jouent entre eux en fait ils peuvent
mettre beaucoup de punto c'est un peu
dangereux
c'est un petit peu dangereux
bon ça se passe
ça se passe ni bien ni mal pour le
moment on sait pas trop où on est encore
dans cette phase après une heure de jeu
de combat d'ouverture de sortie
d'ouverture
je suis assez confiant quand même pour
finir où déjà le fait que fabiano
réfléchissent beaucoup il n'a pas été
très précieux dans ce tournoi
je ne vois pas être assez précis pour
battre ali reza après faut toujours
faire attention aux bêtes blessées il
revient vraiment forceps caruana et qui
sait un
tous les saints kenyan intéresse que
cheyrou jack gagne ou perde à vrai dire
ils n'ont pas intérêt à nul ils ont
adhéré saut à skis perdre pour qu'il ya
un gros regroupement massif
soit à ce qu'ils gagnent pour vraiment
éliminer caruana mais ils n'ont pas
intérêt de nul
et maxi réfléchis va envoyer le simcoe
je pense
donc 5
l'idée c'est quoi
sur pions prend il veut quoi
il veut prendre en c4 et l'idée c'est
que sur fou prend 1,4 faut prendre
quatre points quatre îles à tour d un
math
c'est ça l'idée de maxime avec 5 c'est
de s'ouvrir la colonne pour la tour en
est sûr c'est prend des cinq qui
menacent fou prend 1,4 il veut cavaliers
g5
des pros de cinq épreuves trois pions
problème trois tours prend des 5
avec pion de moins mais il ya une
activité sur la quatrième avec la tour
et ça doit aller
en plus c'est son genre de position sa
maxime
à jouer le a4 vous m'avez dit dans la
chaîne des syndicats comme ça disait
qu'il est noir et est même mieux
suis pas tout à fait d'accord évidemment
à long terme les noirs sont mieux parce
qu'ils ont beaucoup contre mauvais fou
et il ya des cases notamment la casse c4
mais le truc c'est qu'à court terme il
peut y avoir une
problème avec la dame on l'a vu dans une
vente un peu bizarre on mettait la dame
en c4 la dame reparti en b1 et après
cavaliers des deux baies 5 elle se
faisait complètement fermée
donc c'est on crée un
dame c'est 400 m haies dames c4 déjà
tout à l'heure c'était pas terrible
alors d'armes français quatre prises ces
quatre fous des deux
cavaliers ici et il va jouer rock
cavaliers dessin qui va jouer avec ses 3
est ce que il peut un jour sur b52
prendre prendre et rejouer colonna comme
tout à l'heure
peut-être
ces évolutions complexes les amis
pas facile de juger en fait c'est des
trucs long terme
avec beaucoup de calculs au milieu pour
voir si on a le temps de pas se faire
avoir entre guillemets
dame c4 pour moi à première vue ça
passait un je vous le dis franchement
après quand on a regardé c'était
beaucoup plus complexe qu'il n'y
paraissait donc après est ce que dans ce
tempo là comme il ya quatre qui a été
jouée entre temps ça passe mieux on va
voir ce qu a joué maxime autres qu'on
avait vu une variante dangereux c'était
genre kébé 6 ça marche et comment
c'était ces trois dames c'est qu'adam b1
et tout d'un coup c'était cavaliers des
deux baies 5 on se faisant fermer la
dame de manière assez étonnante mais la
belle et elle est déjà bloqué dans le
réseau de gaz blanche là
donc ça peut être dangereux
et dans la partie de maxime du coup il a
envoyé le simcoe et grâce à ce moyen il
s'est décidé pour eux 5 et ça a l'air
d'être un très bon coup
5 être un très joli coup pour
maxime donc je vais pas être l'idée
après pions prend 1,5 puis on prend ces
quatre maintenant la tour fait action
sur la colonne des et après fou prend
1,4 vous prend 1,4 tour prend 1,4 à tour
d un échec et mat donc c'est l'idée de
5,2 pas se laisser dominer avec ce pion
qui resterait arriérés mais
d'immédiatement casser la structure
blanche
ça a l'air d'être un bon coup et sur ses
prend des cinq du coup avec l'idée
d'attaquer le cavalier cavaliers g5
replace le cavalier attaque le fou est
sûr que l'on prend qu'épreuve trois
pions pointe trois tours condé 5 les
noirs ont un pion - mais ils ont un
énorme avantage de développement et
d'activités et les pions blancs plus son
petit peu détruit on va réussir à se
placer et à mon avis a récupéré le pion
sans trop forcer
je pense 5 et était le bon coup en tout
cas c'est un coût qui paraît correct et
qui en plus est dans le style de maxime
donc c'est parfait
shyqeri interne émergents prestance
comment ça marche concrètement comment
on sait qu'ils utilisent pas juste a
terminé à son âme et il utilise juste à
temps plein à fond
mais il réussit à bien l'utiliser quoi
pour être bon en
aux échecs par correspondance
actuellement il faut très bien savoir
manipuler la turbine c'est pas facile
je pense que ça les chances de 15
positions visuellement non mais si vous
vous rappelez de la partie de maxime
contre anthony girard oav al kanz et en
début d'année
partant d'une finale plus ou moins nul
il a mis une énorme pression en tonnes
et anton a eu vraiment de la chance de
s'en sortir donc qui sait peut-être
qu'on peut répéter le scénario de vay
qui est à voir poussette de maxime par
la suite
autrement dit sa rentrée en autriche a
annoncé pas aux échecs par
correspondance à turbiner
est autorisée d'ailleurs c'est une
proposition de vlad pour les tournois
d'échecs en ligne c'était d'autoriser
l'utilisation de la turbine en partant
du principe que comme on pouvait pas
contrôler son utilisation est que
trichet était trop simple
l'autorisé régler les problèmes de
triche dans les tournois c'est loin
d'être idiot à vrai dire
pour les tordant en ligne en vrai c'est
pas idiot comme composition
turbine au final ah oui mais y aurait
plus de triche
oui non mais les humains sont quand même
utile
puisque de toute façon c'est des joueurs
qui sait de la turbine qui gagnent
quasiment systématiquement les tournois
autant l'autorisé à tout le monde
s'assoit dégoûter les joueurs qui n ont
pas la turbine à mais ceux qui
n'utilisent pas la turbine sont déjà
dégoûté en fait
donc en fait ça fait que mettre tout le
monde sur un pied d'égalité
et puis un moment donné tu va peut-être
réussir à mieux guide et à turbinage ou
un meilleur coût en fait
donc au moins
d'accord avec le avec là pour le coup
c'est incontrôlable donc ça existe donc
quand on est pragmatique on s'adapte
assez ça en fait comme tout le monde le
fait autant
autant l'autorisé quoi
si tu peux pas le contrôler autant
l'autorisé en fait
ce que tout ministre ce passionné de
jazz comme et non c'est pas les mêmes
règles sur les parties à par
correspondance chasse comme là c'est pas
autorisé sur les parties par
correspondance officielle c'est autorisé
c'est comme le dopage autant l'autorisé
puisque les mecs se dopent sans se faire
prendre
l'impression que le dopage
s'est officieusement un petit peu
autorisé cyril tavus pas trop hein
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de substances
qui sont autorisés
du coup si ça choquant est un bon joueur
par quoi commence à être aussi un très
bon second dans exactement tu as tout
compris
quelle horreur mais après c'est quoi
l'intérêt d'apprendre à jouer aux échecs
d'après à sa huitième c'est que pour les
tournois en ligne c'est pas pour les
tourner en réel
il y avait sa chance alors stone au
début de l'arrivée des traqueurs des
cartes c'était interdit au début mais
comme ces indétectable c'est devenu
autorisé pour les tourner en ligne va
mais au bout d'un moment fait quand tu
peux pas empêcher quelque chose s'il
autorise
les carreaux utilisant engine pense pas
mais on peut pas savoir quand tu peux
rien savoir donc
autant l'autorisé en fait ce que dans le
tas des gens qui gagnent tous les
tournois sur internet on a forcément qui
utilise donc après écarts où je pense
pas et car le truc c'est que les gens
qui le bat se font ban
donc ça peut dissuader ceux qui
l'utilisent de l'utiliser contre hikaru
du coup ça devient possible de gagner
mais il faut ça être humain
avec une turbine et plus forte qu'une
turbine salle
donc
vrai dire tu es maxime avec une turbine
contre moi et avec une turbine maxime
bas
ses assesseurs aux siens
ces unités de vlad qui est pas si débile
que ça en vrai
est vraiment sûr que ça qu'ils aient pu
survivre sur la turbine a oui ça on en
est sûr et
ça on en est sûr
max hall a oui bah une turbine salle est
meilleur que max fin
ce que propose différentes comment la
stream parce que des fois on joue mieux
il ya certes un coup on est plus fort
que la turbine à vrai dire c'est rare
mais ça arrive
si tu peux être plus fort que la turbine
rien qu'un coup sûr 500 en fait tu vas
gagner 10% de partie c'est énorme
tu feras 9 nuls une victoire ce qui est
beau quoi
ce que l'humain complète ce que les
ordis ne comprennent pas ou parce qu'on
est capable d'orienter la turbine a
quant elle hésite les deux en fait on va
pouvoir l'aider sur les quatre
forteresse ou alors pas comprendre que
c'est nul et nous on va le comprendre
pour faire des exemples un peu grossier
on va pouvoir l'aider dans les
ouvertures parce qu'on peut avoir des
nouveautés parce qu on a fouillé une
position pendant 25 heures et que on est
plus fort que du coup une turbine en 30
secondes donc il ya pas mal de cas de
figure on va l'aider en vrai
donc tu vas aller d'éclairement site est
très fort tu va aider la turbine
est il pas risqué gens les plus fortunés
soit avantagé grâce à des turbines plus
performantes rabat aussi haut moi j'en
verrai 50001 je remettrai une énorme
turbine 1 bah oui là ce serait une
dizaine de rtx 3090
avec les processeurs msi qui tournera à
plein régime en eau
le sponsor msi qui pourrait caries
ça pourrait louer les ordinateurs
quantiques attention
bah oui ah bah là on se présenterait un
petit peu dans les tournois
mais au moins on serait sur un pied
d'égalité égalité aide
ici l'art est le il se met à jouer des
trois d'échec sur internet
ah bah oui
4 ou 5 arte x montant paraît la bonne on
l'envoie en prendre 40 50 bulli 15 15
mais c'est mieux ça que faire foule
tournoi non vérifiées en fait qui tape à
vérifier si les gens l'utilisent ou pas
autant autant le
autant l'autorisé très honnêtement en
fait faut soit faire soit l'un soit
l'autre soit vraiment s'assurer que les
gens n'utilisent pas turbines sur
internet et c'est possible
mais vraiment le faire soit l'autorisé
en fait mais pas un entre deux
l'entre-deux ne sert à rien en fait
toujours pas de cave d'ali reza
malheureusement il a joué le drame c'est
cointreau dont je vous avais parlé et du
coup dame de france et quatre pions
france et quatre fous des deux il
fallait juger hyper compliqué moi
j'aurais jugé comme égal mais j'ai
l'impression que la turbine n'est pas
d'accord comme vous dites que c'est une
faute
comment faire pour vérifier pas obliger
les joueurs à jouer soit par le soin
depuis un club d'échecs quand on fait
des tournois avec de l'argent soit
obligé que les joueurs jouent dans des
clubs avec des arbitres soient que les
joueurs payent des arbitres pour qu'ils
viennent à domicile pour vérifier
tu peux le faire en fait
les joueurs
tout sera obligée de se faire contrôler
pour jouer et du coup
ça marche
oui mais bon du coup ça s'appelle déjà
de la corruption il ya déjà des preuves
qu'ils peuvent tu peux voir par les
virements bancaires qui sont faits il ya
un arbitre qui peut parler tu as déjà tu
prends des risques si tu fais de la
corruption d'arbitrés prend des risques
tu prends déjà clairement deyris
un arbitre ça skowron mais dans ces cas
là il ya plus de police dans les rues
parce qu'un policier ça se corrompt
aussi et ses annonces humains arbitres
eu celui qui voudrait corrompre un
arbitre prendrait prendraient déjà de
vrais risques
non là je peux déjà commencé à faire des
enquêtes à
ce que j'entends déjà ce film et quand
ils jouent des toits sur internet en
plus de la webcam ouais mais ça sert pas
à grand chose à vrai dire
tu mets une petite oreillette dans
l'oreille et s'est terminée il ya trop
d'argent en jeu dans ces tournois du
cumul tous les tournois de haut niveau
avec les prize pool l'année prochaine je
crois que tu vas arriver déjà à plus de
2 millions d'euros de prix
peu importe on n'est pas là pour parler
de ça
mémé faut juste savoir en fait on parle
et dont on parle ça parler d échec par
correspondance en fait sa discussion
pour dire que échec par correspondance
en fait c'est autorisé d'utiliser les
ordi mais que les êtres humains font un
être humain qui est très fort comme ça
chez qui rien on va faire progresser
alors dit en fait il va être plus fort
yat-il et enfin par concernant soit il
ya même des championnats du monde par
correspondance un sujet intéressant
donc intéressant le dame c4 donc dame
français et 4 dépensé 4 il faut réussir
à juger cette position moi j'aurais jugé
comme
cool pour les noirs parce que tu t'es
gagner la case des cinq états quand même
le bon fou même site en manque d espace
mais après c'est peut-être pas le cas
peut-être qu'on peut forcer le bessin
qui échangent et se gagner là colonna
cette rue main qui te revient
complètement
et inversement c'est un genre de duo tu
pourrais imaginer ça on est parties
rapides aussi un
mes champignons par correspondance à de
très belles parties d'ailleurs parfois
canton il tient un tel truc a déjà été
jouée par correspondance il ya plein de
coups deux parties qui sont qui ont été
joués par correspondance qui sont repris
à haut niveau 1
l'adventure ces morts n'a à vrai dire
avec vlad on avait eu un projet
il ya quelques années
c'est un projet intéressant une dizaine
dizaine d'années on a vu un projet de
faire un tournoi en partie rapide
par équipes avec un mec qui joue dans
l'équipe du cou et à deux moments
pendant la partie il peut appuyer sur un
bouton
du coup pour arrêter la partie pour
demander un temps mort et il ya des gars
de son équipe qui ont trente secondes
pour lui dire ce que pensent l'ordi de
la position et pour communiquer avec lui
et donc ils avaient le droit à faire
d'eux on appelait ça des pit stops en
fait des arrêts aux stands avec 30
secondes de communication avec l'équipe
que le public pouvait entendre et où il
avait loué il avait le droit de lui
communiquer
le
les lignes que donner l'ordinateur
et deux fois deux fois par joueur en
fait pendant la partie
c'était deux pit stop par partie c'est
assez marrant parce que
ouais faut bien prendre les speeds les
pit stops au bon moment quoi
et tu devais le demande et sur le coup
de l'adversaire c'était pas pendant que
c'est à toi de jouer tu avais pas le
droit de demander le pit stop tu avais
le droit de demander le speed stop pour
le prochain coup en fait
donc tu pouvais pas appelé demander ce
qu est une tactique qui marchent fallait
demander en amont quoi de ton cou
super idée mais pourquoi sans ordi juste
avec les cerveaux des équipiers à parce
que c'est beaucoup plus marrant avec les
ordis parce qu'il faut que les équipiers
soit assez malin pour bien analyser et
pouvoir répondre aux questions du joueur
c'est beaucoup plus marc look
que les équipiers et l'ordi en même
temps
comme un temps mort bah les 30 secondes
ou à toi tu parles à ton équipe est là
l'adversaire peut pas parler à la sienne
mais
le problème c'est que dès que l'un fera
l'autre en ferrain juste après vous
passez ferkane ah bah c'est pour ça
qu'il faut être marlou peut-être que tu
dois jamais utiliser de pit stops
peut-être que tu dois en utiliser un
peut-être que tu doit on utiliser deux
en fait
on ne sait pas
j'ai des crises potentielles moins fort
que le joueur du coup besoin de l'ordi
pour calculer bas par exemple du pouvoir
maxime qui jouent et tu pourras voir une
équipe soit baky et vlad qu'ils soient
derrière qui regarde
qui regardent les coudes ordi et je n'ai
pas taillé nouvelle à un moment donné
ils demandent un pit stop parce qu'il
sait plus trop quoi faire il veut avoir
la direction de l'ordi pour savoir qu
allez-vous jouer et du coup il faut que
les gars qui regarda qui regardent la
partie en même temps soit assez malin
pour bien guidée avec que 30 secondes
il avoue ce projet il a été abandonné
c'est un projet qu'on avait une dizaine
d'années
l'attesté où on avait fait des petits
des petits bêta test c'est assez marrant
alors un romantique et chacun jeu non
mais ce qui est marrant c'est que quand
tu casses en fait ce truc là tu peux
entendre ce que disent les équipes aux
joueurs et tu peux voir s'ils
réussissent à réaliser ce qu'il faut
réaliser ou pas
c'était assez marrant quand tu regardes
parce qu'évidemment quand elle public a
accès à ce que disent les joueurs
et l'idée c'est que l'ordinateur et
l'être humain soit plus
l'un contre l'autre mais soit ensemble
en fait
avec les joueurs aient connaissance des
pistes soit de l'autre à 20 ans bien sûr
qu'il n'aurait pas connaissance du pit
stop de l'autre
mais c'était assez marrant comme truc
nullement ferroudja il n'a pas pris je
sais pas il veut laisser d'empreintes
pions prend
essayé de taper avec un b sinko
grave télégéniques comme construit
l'idée c'était c'était pour rendre
l'idée du concept et 5 de maximois
révélations l'idée de ce concept là
c'était de rendre le truc marrant parce
que tu as les discussions entre les
joueurs pendant la partie et c'est assez
drôle
de ce fait qui s'affrontent sur les
quatre communes qui les conseillent un
carnage ray il ya des trucs marrants à
faire mais malheureusement
saint jean t peu avec la linge ans et la
seconde entre états mais en vrai avec
wallon avait fait une bêta d'une
émission télé malheureusement le
producteur est mort est décédée avant
qu'on puisse faire le projet mais en
fait le projet et ressemble à un petit
peu parce que je viens de vous dire en
fait c'est un danse avec les stars avec
les échecs
est en fait le projet qu'on avait eu
pour la télé il découle de cette idée
qu'on avait eu de base que je viens de
vous dire c'était en fait faire jouer
deux personnes connues l'une contre
l'autre
et pendant à deux moments de la partie
elle pouvait faire appeler un appel à un
pro qui lui expliquer les enjeux de la
position pendant deux minutes
mais en fait nous de base ont trouvé que
c'était plus cool de faire ça avec les
ordis et les joueurs professionnels
mais en vrai il ya une dizaine d'années
on avoir eu l'idée du poc chef mais en
milieu d'après moi
et antoine guiraud qui jouent
et rient pub aide
et recherche énorme c'était beaucoup
plus qu'on voulait faire avec lattes
c'était beaucoup plus drôle donc il a
fait puis on prend des cinq ça va
rentrer dans la variante qu'on a vu
david wells a un toit un très bon
commenté autant de game en ligne le haut
niveau ça peut aider pas non david wei
la boufballe dans ce tournoi il devait
perdre compte nexans et de les perdre
contre ici plein quand il a la baraka
je pense pas qu'avec ce format
puis sort dix équipiers ne sauraient pas
encore plus vers des nuls j'en sais rien
mais déjà ce serait ça aurait été en
rapide et puis ça aurait été marrant
surtout
de toute façon faut tout faire pour
sortir des parties longues à rallonge
qui sont reloués
caruana et carmona il as dame prend b3
intéressant il veut jouer vraiment avec
le dessin qui est jouée cette structure
4 sk mais fermé écoute moi non plus en
fait pour te dire la vérité
il vise à bien mettre six minutes de pub
par heures en écoute
c'est leur droit le plus fondamental
et donc maxime ça enchaîne
il a fait tout reprend 1,5 ok
ça à faire cavaler il n'a pas fait plus
on prend comme regarder ça à faire
cavalier prend pions prend
les rois et fuites pour empêcher tour
sept cavaliers ses trois tours à ces
8es tour c'est qu'à moi j'aime bien les
noirs mais bon c'est une question de
goût 1
donga
ils ont échangé
supprimant est-ce que tu peur expliqué
win ans gisait donc on voulait voir avec
la de faire un faire une émission de
télé à l'époque mais même tourné un
pilote c'est pour dire qu'on avait bien
avancé sur le sujet c'était y'a qu'un
vrai je vous dédie dix ans maintenant
c'est simple j'avais 19 ans et demi 20
ans c'est à 15 ans et l'idée ouais
l'idée c'était de faire jouer des gens
connus à la télé avec
avec l'intervention de pro deux fois
pendant la partie de deux minutes pour
expliquer la position joueurs amateurs
et l'idée c'était de commenter la partie
de voir ce que l'amateur demandé aux
prouesses qui répondait ça paraissait
assez marrant et de voir le joueur
amateur complètement incapable de mettre
en place ce que lui disait le grand
maître quoi
donc c'est assez marrant comme comme
concept ce que tu expliques un petit peu
ce qu'il faut faire les enjeux de la
position et trois coups après ce que tu
as dit ça marche plus évidemment
et et l'idée c'était c'était un petit
peu de faire un vrai faire un truc comme
ça qui nous paraissaient marrant et de
faire de faire quelque chose de vivant
quoi
parce que trop les amateurs nan mais
c'est 2 c'est assez marrant tous les
amateurs qui jouent en il a besoin d'un
coup de main puis en fait n'arrive pas
vraiment à bien l'aider ça demande aussi
aux gars qui est fort de bien aider le
joueur c'est assez drôle en fait
le poc non mais c'est bien mieux que le
coach aime pas en fait
par son père il ya 15 ans
sardasht avec l'âge il avait 10 en 12
ans
enfin on c'était sympa
j'ai pris un f3 jouer way maxime à deux
pions de moins mais pions des blancs
sont des gueux
fouache 4 et 1 fois je souhaite à quoi
je pense pas je pense sa priorité avec
les noirs c'est de ramener ta tour en
jeu et taper les pions 1
mais peut-être tu commences paroisse et
fuite pour empêcher tout recettes
à maxime n'est pas moins bien là mais à
la question c'est ce qu'on peut jouer
actifs pour essayer de gagner ou est-ce
que c'est dangereux il faut faire
annuler des deux côtés
maj sur le tour c'est 8 pour commencer
de toute façon tu menaces tour c1
il va bouger son cavalier en d2 pour
empêcher tour c4 est maintenant roi et
fuite
nul arrange max
est dur à dire je pense que oui à vrai
dire
parce que caruana c'est pas sûr qu'ils
gagnent shirov ça a déjà fait nul
alireza ça a fait un nul contre fabi
rions pas de fin ouais mais je pense que
firoud position elle est pas mal à fuir
ou en fait la nouveauté de caruana c'est
un peu un peu de l'eau en vrai
ça paraît pas hyper dangereux
veut faire une partie au long cours avec
cette structure depuis un peu bizarre
qui empêche ses 5 mai avec apsys 6000 le
centre
c'est mieux pour les noirs mais
pas pourquoi les blancs serez mieux
honnêtement
être que fabiano il veut une partie au
long cours essayez de faire craquer
psychologiquement firoud déjà dans une
finale un petit peu comme a pu le faire
car la scène
c'est vraiment dommage qu'on n'ait pas
la caméra je voudrais vraiment l'avoir
la caméra de giroux déjà aujourd'hui
super bien maxime moi j'aime bien ça
pose après la 2 pions - quand même
la pression c'est pas ça la cgf mais
c'est les coups les plus chics tour
assez vite qui a aidé 2 droit et fuite
j pat est actif si tu as réussi à
rentrer
avec tour ces trois tours détroit a
commencé à taper la quatrième manche et
ça peut aller assez vite
après c'est vrai que si tu rentres il
rentre en hausse est aussi
osef si sa fille si j'ai peur de tours 7
on prend des cinq tours tomber cette
envie 4 kgs c3
ça ça peut être long
assez vite pour interdire cavale et c3
est menacée tour sert
jusqu'à prédire à quoi ça sert de
tolérer parce que si ces caïds et de tu
va de toute façon verte aura ses huit
probablement c'est dommage de tolérer
carré lisse et 3
à moins que tu considère qu'après avoir
fui de qualité 2 tf6 parce que tu as
interdite ou recettes c'est ça l'idée et
du coup sûr kaïs étroite a peut-être
tour s'est vite maintenant
ah ok
pour ça qu'il réfléchit cavaliers à 4
tours c4
qu est ce pour ça qu'il réfléchit aussi
longtemps il compare
en d1 on met un c'est bizarre
prend b1 c'est trop bizarre
des changes une bonne pièce contre une
pièce non développés et le jeu est très
dynamique
faby je me rends pas compte du danger
que ça peut représenter mais j'imagine
que si c'est sa prépa et qu'il a
beaucoup analysé il doit connaître la
structure de pions
donc là les raisins après rock food
cette e-menace pions points qui feront
h4 va sûrement y avoir g3 pour
l'empêcher s'est joué à tempo
depuis on va il a dû étudier le truc
avec cb et savoir que c'est dangereux
bon
ok
vérifier si on n'a pas une caméra
ambulante de fuir ou qu'il arrive mais
non et maxime qui commence par tour
assez vite c'est quand même ce qu'il y
avait de plus logique
c'est le coup le plus logique à jouer
maxime je le sens pas être en danger
dans cette partie
je vois pas maxime se faire mettre en
danger
après
la question c'est vraiment de savoir
si ça passe ou pas
j'apparais les échecs c'est un jeu très
concret
pièce essentielle muxel d'antoine oui
mais il ya deux pions moins
cavalia
car il y en a trois et bizarre quand
même 1 2 d2 il repart vers 4 et
contrôler des cases il a joué quoi
j'ai pas pu voir
il a joué qui a aidé devrait paraître
cavaliers à 3 est un peu bizarre là il a
plus de rebond
qui a validé deux c'est logique hein il
veut faire tour 7 au prochain bref lui
tour à tour ses sept
mais on dit caruana et mieux
ouais ça a l'air d'être petite poucette
ça c'est sûr mais bon c'est si grave
cal f 4k et détroit ils veulent en faire
ma long terme a annoncé suivant quel
point c'est grave
c'est très très compliqué
par la cave on va mettre ça comme ça
signifie rousset très très compliqué
c'est sûr que c'est les blancs qui sont
qui joue qui prétendent al'avantage
ouais je comprends ce que veut faire
fabiano ils jouent petit avantage long
terme en sachant que firent ucia est
sous pression il veut lui joué pendant
des plombes
c'est clair qu'il veut faire ça
fabiano
il va pouvoir vie c'est un peu la case 5
la poussée c5 est bloqué
c'est vraiment dommage qu'on n'ait pas
la caméra je suis je suis attristé tout
comme vous
repartir un peu sur maxime alireza ça va
être une partie au long cours maxime
lhassa lors des tremblements déjà quasi
décisif et il envoie la tour en c2 j'ai
l'impression maxime
ok alors là deux solutions
trois solutions à vrai dire soit
cavalier e 4 le coût pour moi le plus
logique à première vue parce qu'on vient
taper sur f 6 cavaliers b3 j'aime pas
juste se faire virer par b6 est mal
placé mais à cavalia fin aussi manon
katurian ces deux parce que ça veut
cavaliers trois étapes et
vallières fin
j'aurais juste voir une variante comme
ça ce que ça donne genre admettons qu'on
joue un truc comme ça
et ça c'est juste turbo droit à vrai
dire
pas tomber cinq temps b4 pardon
sa ceinture boudreau
donc c'est ça l'idée maxime qui avalait
a fait un tour c4 et drôle
je vous ai fait nul est sûre d'être
qualifiée non
on va dire que là il à 95% ci fait nul
il est à 98
en tout cas annulé un très bon résultat
pour ali reza très clairement
c'est noir tout le monde fait des trois
avec les noirs qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire
faut espérer qu'ils doublent et blanc
sur les deux dernières ou que à la
dernière ronde son adversaire soit
obligée de forcer et qu'il ait une
chance de contrer
voir ce que ça donne
on va voir si ali reza réussi à tenir
voir si maxime réussi à faire la
différence
les parties sont complexes ans les amis
nul n'est pas un mauvais résultat pour
maxime ça dépend de ce qui se passe
autour
il faudra un petit peu réussit à un
moment donné pour maxime
c'est précisément pour être top pour
maxime du coup il a raté une petite
occasion
microscopiques mais mais il a raté une
petite okaz il aurait gagné hier il
aurait les mêmes à paris mais
aujourd'hui fait nul ça aurait été un
super résultat
là il va falloir qu'ils gagnent la
prochaine avec les blancs et à la
dernière ce sera un peu la roulette mais
je pense que la stratégie de maxime est
correct
on va on va faire nul aujourd'hui on
gagne demain et après la dernière
peut-être même qu'une nul suffit et 6
nuls ne suffit pas peut-être que
l'adversaire sera obligé de force avec
les blancs et maxime sera la rencontre
pour se qualifier
il peut doubler les blancs sur la fin
mais il peut doubler les blancs sur la
fin donc
maxime il doit pas se précipiter
aujourd'hui si son adversaire force pas
il prend la nulle et puis on verra par
la suite
en calant decarone aille mieux dans la
finale
[Musique]
dans le monde où il réussit à vis et la
case de 5
on va faire des heureux clairement pour
se prendre la casse des 4es supprimer ce
cavalier on va être le truc c'est que si
fait cavalier prend pions prend
cavaliers prend pions prend à les noirs
ont le contrôle de la casse des 4
et donc le cavalier a priorité sur la
case donc il va plutôt jouer puis on
prend pour mettre le cavalier en d4 et
laisser les noirs avec le cavalier 17
qui a beaucoup de mal à retrouver cette
case là en revanche faut regarder ce qui
se passe sur ces 5
qui pour moi une vraie option
pas clair
je sais pas
jugez pas l'idée c'est 5 ça me paraît
être formé à peut-être un truc pour fabi
ce que le truc c'est que sur plus on
prend fou prend les noirs vont carrément
être bien
ont quand même le contrôle à mieux
peut-être kg cinq cavaliers f4 c'est ça
l'idée
ok non ça ça va pas donc il faudra faire
cavalier prend
mais ça ça a l'air d'aller pour
le cavalier jane qui revient vers 4
tu en prends et ai je donc ces cinq pour
moi c'est la grosse question c'est le
coup que je jouerai avec les noirs
ce qu'à vrai dire on comprend l'idée
ainsi on fait un coup lambda georges et
si ce n'est pas si con
il va peut-être vouloir échanger une
pièce
s'installer ouais mais là encore il ya
ces 5
petit cavalier f4
courage des 8
vous voulez dire qu'il y aura plus de
ses cinq puisque à chaque fois qu'on va
faire c'est cinq lauréats qui avait
prend des 5 comprend et de 6
ha et sur ses cinq avocats vallée f4
bordel c'est ça l'idée menaces qui les
prend dé 5,6 et tout ouvrir
c'est ça l'idée
c'est malin et du coup car elle et b6
maintenant puis on prend fou prend
qu'avaient les g5 et on tape là
c'est malin
car il y avait quatre un coup d'enfoirés
qui menacent cac et prend et e6
ok donc c'est loin d'être simple en fait
pour les noirs
merci à bobby fischer 2
je suis pas corps que celle où parce que
tu voulais cavalli f4 qui on prend et
qui éprouvent 6
honnêtement les feux c'est un coup que
je comprends tout à fait
en fait j'aurais joué à feu russie à feu
et f mes cavaliers f4 est vraiment malin
je pensais qu'ils voulaient carlier des
cats échanger jouer la pression en fait
cavalier f4 c'est interdit c'est 5 tu va
interdire à long terme
et dans la game de max
il ya eu cavalli eu quatre tours ces
quatre
ans à partir entoure cette offrande
b4 et tour c'est un peut-être pour tour
c'est
7.4 c'est cette
fois h3 idée de marloux donc ça peut
aller pour les noirs
intérêt pour maxime on va retourner un
peu sur la partie d'alireza vraiment
désolé pour les cavs comme je vous
disais
ouais parce qu'il peut être sous
pression et caruana ce serait incroyable
le retour de caruana caruana au forceps
à
caruana si caruana revient dans l'ide
aujourd'hui en battant fier ou déjà
franchement c'est un grand monsieur
c'est un saint c'est un très très grand
at latin
parce que il n'est pas en forme il au
fond du trou il sort d'un championnat
des états unis au forceps aussi est si
réussi là au fond du trou comme il est à
revenir dans l'ide c'est incroyable
et ouais c'est un vrai champion ainsi
fait ça
parce que franchement moi caruana je le
voyais pas revenir et aujourd'hui je le
voyais pas mettre une grosse game après
comme j'ai dit attention les grands
joueurs dans les grands moments c'est
toujours dangereux mais messi réussit à
battre un alireza en pleine forme en
pleine possession de ses moyens alors
que lui il est dans le dur qu'il est
dans le doute depuis maintenant presque
un an et qui réussit à te sortir la
victoire contre gand dellus après avoir
sué contre séville en être sorti d'un
championnat d'italie difficile il arrive
là bout de course bout d'énergie et il
te sort la wind partie naf avec les
blancs ce serait vraiment un grand
monsieur
je tends le point fort de famille
n'est-il pas d'avoir un niveau faible
extrêmement haut je crois que c'est un
peu le côté ritalin c'est un peu le côté
[ __ ] le côté il se bat tout le temps
jusqu'au bout il a joué bessines qu
antonio guirao je rentrais plus à tour 7
pour tour c'est un tour c'est cette
pourquoi pas
doit vouloir tout reprend des quatre
tours 7 plutôt
rappel car on n'a rien à perdre contre
une arme en partie en guerre avec les
biens ya pas longtemps oui oui la ville
avait complètement gaffes et un sponsor
et j'étais complètement hors forme
caruana il réussit pas à retrouver son
niveau depuis maintenant plus d'un an et
réussir comme ça dans un moment
difficile à se remobiliser à sortir des
grosses games est vraiment très
compliqué
on se souvient d'ailleurs de maximin qui
s'était qui avait perdu la confiance à
weick et qui avait vécu quand même un
des buts candidats difficile un petit
peu
englué dans les problèmes qu'il avait
vécu quelques mois avant et c'est très
difficile de retrouver la confiance et
les échecs c'est un jeu un peu comme
tous les sports mais lorsque la
confiance fui c'est très difficile de
retrouver son meilleur niveau et il ya
que les très grands joueurs qui
réussissent à à se sublimer à réussir
malgré tout à sortir des game incroyable
et là fabien aussi réussi l'a pas encore
réussi mais si réussi à se qualifier
dans ce tournoi ce sera un exploit
majuscule 1
le problème c'est pas de survie de
suivre la tchèque la turbine c'est sûr
avec la turbine chasse comme mais c'est
ça sur une chaise comme c'est de la
turbine est un
on sera incroyable là fabien aussi
réussi à se qualifier ici sera
incroyable et à maxime qui a joué le roi
et fuite maintenant est logique
je pense pas qu'ils soient moins bien
ouart
va voir maxime
est ce que ça peut faire un truc comme
ça
l'impression que maxime peut même la
gagner en fait je suis confiant pour max
je suis confiant pour max en fait
beaucoup moins pour ali reza
de service qui remonte à six points
ouais m'attend ils sont à cinq ennemis
les gars
ils étaient ils étaient dans le groupe
des battus s'abstient
donc en gros zf non
aussi bien préparé que fariba ya un peu
de guérilla un peu de carlson meiway
pour moi c'est top 2 avec karl scène
une pause correct
mais il n'a une pause correct mais en
fait je me sens caruana les
versions avec son cavalier à f4 en fait
il n'est pas perdant alireza mais ça va
être relou
c'est caruana forcément le mieux préparé
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est celui
qui est la meilleure mémoire en fait
après faut aussi noter qu'hier il a
galéré à gagner en plus 4 contre grande
est lui sain il avait une position à
absolument écrasante contre gand d'élus
s'est il a galéré à la terminer
rappel viande c'est des idées ouais
c'est un gros travailleur je pense
qu'ils travaillent énormément caruana
peut-être plus que les autres et du coup
ils regardent plus ces fichiers il s'en
rappelle plus il a une capacité
d'ingestion d'information qui est plus
grande que tous les autres donc au delà
de la préparation c'est aussi le joueur
et maxime labitte fait une position à
plus 4 il défonce vendée u sera oui y'a
même pas de partie l'arrêt
maxime +4 contre un joueur comme ça
c'est
terminé instante
une combine caruana mvl tuba car le sel
en fait
très concrètement
win carbone fait chaque arras n en fait
pas tout à fait mais tu as un joueur qui
battrait carlsen
faudrait faire une fusion quoi
selon john f n'est pas d'ailleurs qu'il
n'est qu'à roanne veulent en quelque
sorte oui
sans descendre aussi il en a
on verra on verra on verra mais un
parti sont tendus des deux côtés la côté
français mais ce maxime je commence à
prendre confiance
je commence
à prendre confiance
ce genre d'initiative en échec ont dû
aux noms et les mains cerveau mais pas
en dur
ces cinq ça le problème de ces cinq y
avait la force et qu'elle prend des 5
j'en prends des cinq six échecs et ça
c'est qu'à table ce cas la position qui
s'ouvre et ça rentre de partout
à vrai dire le problème d'alireza c'est
qu'ils menacent pas du tout ces 5 et
donc il n'a pas trop de plans ces genres
de position ça ressemble un peu aux cars
bafin dans l'esprit pas dans la position
mais dans l'esprit un peu on carlsbad
dont on a parlé ya pas si longtemps avec
fab
les noirs sont probablement pas perdant
mais le truc c'est que t'as pas de plan
si tu enlève ton roya cavale et prend
aussi si tu fais cavalli en fuite ben
car il y va peut-être venir en d3 il va
taper en c5 tu pourras pas vraiment joué
ses 5 tu reviens avec du cavalier 17 il
va commencer à faire fou j'ai 5 du coup
il va s'octroyer la casse g5 te taper e6
est petit à petit tu vas t'en prie temps
tu vas tu empiré
ces gens opposition à la con où ça va
pas être si grave que ça mais en vrai
c'est ultra sion
didot à défendre
mais ça peut être ultra relou a joué
la veille à 6 kg 4ème et tu perds tu vas
prendre cali des quatre qui est prévu si
ce problème
c'est hyper relou en fait concrètement
c'est hyper relou
maintenant alors genre est plutôt à 6 tu
vas te prendre un point taux à 5 un jour
était vice aide s'il réussit à te [ __ ]
un cavalier en c5 qui va être dans une
sauce genre cahier detroit il aura
turquie ces cinq sous l'oeil jean rythme
à un cavalier angers 5-1 cavaliers en c5
et il te tapes qui te tabasse en fait
ils te défonces donc assista pas envie
b6 t'as pas envie qu'ils avaient fui tu
peux pas vraiment
leur est peut-être je rejoins la turbine
est il donne à 6 que j'aurais jamais
deuxième coup c'est déjà tour à 8 avec
qui des tours c'est 8 en fait leur dit
me fait tour à 8,3 j'ai deux tours à ses
c'est un problème en fait
en fait quand l'ordi commencent à
proposer de faire ça c'est un problème
mais je comprends pas ce que t'as rien
envie de jouer à 6 tu veux pas jouer
c'est simple tu peux pas jouer cavalier
a fui tu veux pas jouer j'ai si tu veux
pas jouer tour achevé 8 tu peux pas
jouer et a passé cinq états paroisse ou
huit étapes affoué fuite
c'est horrible en fait la prépa qui l'a
pris c'est hyper malin s'est une
nouvelle fois
homeworks
prépa de chacals et oui travailler huit
heures par jour ça paye et pas qu aux
échecs
j'aimerais passer ton tour est non mais
vraiment alors dit tu proposes tu auras
huit tours ses victoires à 8 tours s'est
vite c'est chaud en fait
tu as 19 minutes et si tu perds tu perds
peut-être ta place aux candidats et à
place de numéro quatre mondial
donc tu es en sueur tu es réellement sûr
c'est très dur à jouer ça c'est vraiment
de la merde
tu sue à grosses gouttes quoi
l'autre à 1h15 il est tranquille il a
ses petits cheveux et ses beaux gosses
ritalin il doit être en chemise beau
gosse
je suis je suis [ __ ] et je le reste et
tu sues quoi
il a dû se manger des bonnes de la bonne
passe ta à midi t'es pas bien
t'es pas bien et du coup tu mets des
pubs pour essayer de te décontracté mais
les pubs ne sauve pas ici
petite pub quand même hein parce que
quand même
il faut un pour un peu se détendre
la petite pub à st
ce qui part quand même pour souffler un
oui les petites pub qui partout vient
à bam ted
méritait de lait petit pépin lost ou
basses
fins poche
los cobos
abbaoui sa part un petit peu
on souffle
des cuatro et sacrée cote il
envoie il veut pas se faire vis et
veut pas se faire à visser
il peut réussir à avoir c'est singo
j'imagine qu'il va faire quoi
ac 1
place foch
qui veut ça en fait
qui est clairement il va être moins bien
mais il va jouer actifs
je me fais plaisir avec les pubs en
avant la plus basse ça fait plaisir
ça fait quand même plaisir en cloud et
quattro donc il veut pas souffrir
s il veut jouer ces cinq en force mais
évidemment ce pion il va être mal placé
les sur cases noires
ah mais c'est pas moi qui met les pubs
en fait fin c'est moi qui l'ait mais
techniquement mais en fait quand je les
mettais pas je me faisais tellement
défoncé j'ai essayé pendant longtemps
lutté contre les pubs mais mais en fait
je peux plus pendant très longtemps et
les moins de pub c'est la seule chaîne
riz et moins de pulser la chaîne
française
avec comme argument que deux minutes de
pub sur la chaîne française rapporté
autant de 30 minutes sur la chaîne
espagnole
j'ai réussi à faire tenir cet argument
pendant plusieurs années mais à un
moment donné c'est devenu impossible
terrible c'est comme ça game
c'est le game
cube aide
ils ont inventé ça non non pas du tout
ça faisait partie de l'argument en fait
malheureusement
c'est terrible
et ses amorties le coût des cas voilà
c'est ça
après vous dire que mon vrai on est la
chaîne la plus regardée même devant deux
chaises comme us donc on fait on fait le
bénin fin
on fait bnf en fait c'est nous qui
payons plus les calmes que les
américains quoi
terrible
donc
toujours pas de calmes sur firoud mais
bon c'est pas si grave
et anthony guiraud maxime ça avance et
ou pas je crois pas un
vrai fil guirao qui peut la perdre à mon
avis
alors après à la décharge de chaises
comme en vrai quand même à la décharge
c'est qu'en vrai j'ai le droit à 10
minutes de pause par heure en vrai je
devrais faire dix minutes de pause par
heure et les six minutes de pub sont
censés passer pendant les dix minutes de
pause
juste
[Musique]
juste moi je les fais pas en fait
les dix minutes de pause enfin je
regarde la partie non-stop mais en fait
ce serait prévu qu à 14h50 je me barre à
15h50 je me barre à 13h50 je me barre
en fait les 6000 depuis deux mois
devrait passer sur les dix minutes et
devrait avoir juste dix minutes 3 3 4
minutes d'écran
caméra en grand sens rien quoi
quoi vrai dire c'est juste que nous on
fait pas de pause
c'est une des différences
sur sur la chaîne internationale et les
pauses jeu passif on diminue tout comme
ils sont en duo ils font peut-être 5 min
5 minutes chacun
tout reprend 1,4 vous proposez wave a
marqué ses cinq épreuves et 7
mais après c'est un choix parce que sur
ma chaîne non pelucheux pas des poses de
deux minutes donc je les fais pas ici
hein
mais nous voilà pour explique
normalement en fait les pubs devrait
être pendant les pauses qui n'ont pas
lieu donc
c'est juste une des spécificités une des
spécificités de mes lives en fait de pas
ne pas faire de pause
et f6 bref 6 a voulu dire peut-être ça
bloquait ça touche la tour déjà
et puis la tourelle repartira sur m6
et sur m6 maman et cavaliers prend
les prises quatre prises cannois mais en
fait un point quatre pays ces cinq tours
b 4 kébé cette tour 17 cas et ses cinq
tours des 8 est ce que c'est si grave
roy g2 chez pas pour éviter les faux h3
tombé 5 ça a l'air d'être assez drôle
drôle
sauf quand je me sois des colis ouais
c'est ça ou qu'elle reçoit des appels
pour des formations
est là et la position d'ali reza
par gagner le temps
un certain nombre de courcy au 40e et
récupéra dans vingt coups
position et complexe ici
voilà c'est tout ça pour dire que les
pubs devrait être moins en moins
dérangeante et que c'est prévu entre
guillemets pour être au monde et pause
maxine je pense ça va échanger en tonnes
qui reste toujours assez à la chaise
maxime qui est pas encore revenu
annequin
les deux parties sont intéressées entend
aujourd'hui
qu'il est ce pas qui a et des cinq
maintenant ce serait différent ils
perdraient plus le pion quoi
maxime est parti fumer la chicha
stalmans sa maxime qui essayent de
revenir en jeu là bas pour des chichas
quoi
jab son qui va faire torah c'est à moi
perso
ces cinq tours c4 quelque chose comme ça
cb tour c'est un pour essayer de
récupérer le pion à
d4 et garder une majorité
en soi qui est prend des quatre ici
soi-même tour c7
et du coup vous voyez la différence
c'est que maintenant le fou de cases
noires il est devenu mauvais et lui
commence à voir le bon fou pour la ya
peut-être cavaliers ses 5,1 mer
maxime sava sa position est complètement
corrects ici
on n'est pas la position de maxime et si
on va sur la position de maxime ça a
l'air d'aller
bon il va la tenir celle là on va voir
ce qui se passe autour à vrai dire
un revers contre eux révèle sur fall
gaye suspense gagner plus maintenant un
fait longtemps que j'ai pu jouer et
maxime s'est plus entraîné je pense que
j'ai perdu mon ascendance sur maxime
non mais je vais pas regarder les amis
les parties des joueurs qui sont
éliminés en fait
on a qui poussent
c'est plus long c'est pas facile de
trouver les joueurs qui sont au paris ne
prête que ça voulait regarder
on ne le sont pas vraiment un jour c'est
le bordel
je pense qu'on doit être plus tôt pour
op art in parce que prête que s'ils
gagnent au noir ça peut être relou en
fait il va être blanc après
je tends ryan c'est sa réponse emballé
quand on va faire en fait il a fait tour
à c'est un vrai
c5 il peut aussi jouer b5 haut de la
tour c 4
comme édition ça peut être très chance
et le coût que je craignais un os 6
0 6 7 a fait coller aujourd'hui faudra
être solide dans la tête à ses seins
demain avec les blancs surtout que fier
rouille c'est sûr qu'il aura ouais il
peut
il a déjà doublé les blancs donc il
pourra plus doublé
mais il triplera pas les noirs donc ça
va en fait il aura une fois noir une
fois à blanc
s'y prête que gagne se départagent pour
voir enfin ça ramène tout le monde âpre
au bout d'un moment paris magic
n'a pas envie d'avoir prête que qui
revient enfin t'as pas envie d'avoir
tout le monde qui revient en fait
la cie perd aujourd'hui faudra être
solide il faut être très solide dans la
tête
toujours pas de caméra
si on va commencer avec les blancs et
les a doublées donc il peut tripler
théoriquement il peut tripler les noirs
mais c'est rarissime de tripler le nord
quoi ça a l'air assez gare enfin pas
vraiment également les bornes congrue
garde semble mener
inconditionnellement à la nulle
bhaskaran à 100% sur ou là pas du tout
non
peuvent s'éviter jusqu'au bout mais
normalement ils finiront par jour
ensemble
ultra nerveux sirois la camrail les
américains ils sont des calmes
supplémentaires
demandez quand même pour voir si on peut
la récupérer
6 maximum du coup ça permet quand ça
enlève des cavaliers c5 surtout reprend
1,4
jenson qui peut même l'arnaqué la gagne
et maxime
fc amiens pour les blancs why me roy g7
non
j'essaye de choper
on va voir
une tentative
au maximum voire c'est vraiment la
partie d'ali reza qui est intéressante
aujourd'hui
ils retentent du temps ils retentent du
temps à
lire tant qu ils ressentent énormément
parce qu'il avait quoi il avait 17 18
minutes pour 21 coups
ça lui fait une minute park où une
minute trente avec le rajout l'aïr tant
que 5 6 minutes il va se retrouver très
mal autant
à partie de fabiano quand même
incroyable
caruana veut tour ses jeux ses cinq
tours c4 ça clairement équivalent et b6
wyatt earp rend fou prend pions prend
pour prend kg 5 et prend aussi ses
immigrés qui arrivent
et il veut mettre la tour en c4 est
attaqué
et 17 en france et 5 bien joué moi je
pensais que c'était juste pour ces deux
de base et les cavaliers mal placé ici
avec l'idée pions frantour eux c'est un
mejia une amélioration de la ligne dans
le tchat je pensais que c'était juste ça
l'idée le carillon b6 est un peu dans la
sauce as et la tour arrivant c'est cette
ya cinq ans l'air mais c'est intéressant
à l'idée donné par le chat
sachez que je pensais que quand saint
malo temps on peut mettre sa pression
oui mais il faut une position complexe
et beaucoup d'avancé au temps et
beaucoup de coups récents à l'adversaire
oui c'est exactement cette situation
hélas rotor ses positions très complexe
quand même s'il ya beaucoup de pièces et
beaucoup d'erreurs encore une vingtaine
de coups à jouer donc il ya il va y
avoir des situations qui n'a pas du tout
anticipé donc il aura pas de calcul en
toile de fond qui l'aideront il va se
retrouver avec moins de dix minutes
on va voir
si ça marche la caméra
je vais prendre un risque ça peut faire
couper le live ce que je vais faire
puisque le live a coupé non
et ça marche
ah ça y est réparé aide
est oui
a barré par hesdin
réparé aide
donc carrément grands maintenant
abbas mérite une petite pub as quand
même ah bah oui là si la pub ne part pas
maman elle ne part jamais un jour mais
une petite aux noms j'en mettrais une
grande demande en 15 minutes sa mairie
trapu évidemment
sa mairie trapu ben
non là ça sue côtier reza quand même un
fabiano qui s'est barré
plus que 9 minutes 20
se qualifie pas après son tournoi à vrai
dire ils à battre enfin il a joué aucun
joueur enfin le seul joueur contre du
top 100 contre qui il a joué c'était
maxime il a fait d'euros un par un on a
quand même affaire au tournoi de
qualification candidat le plus faible de
l'histoire peut-être donc si tu vas
passer que tu mérites pas point bas rhin
là au bout d'un moment pas davantage de
life
hausse est le seul seulement sa deuxième
partie contre un top mondial c'est
contre top mondial il fait nul avec les
blancs sans poussette est hyper avec les
noirs tant mieux s'il y va on est pour
qu'il y aille mais c'est difficile de
dire après le tournoi qui fait oui enfin
sa victoire contre d'ailleurs c'est fou
le plot
d'ailleurs c'est pas top 100 ça chiant
c'est pas top 100
a quand même
eu peu de joueurs du top 100 jusqu'à
maintenant alireza alors il est très
fort il domine le tournant on espère
qu'il y aille c'est pas du tout mon
propos mais ok super content caruana est
ce que c'est que tu es vraiment taillé
pour les candidats c'est une autre
question
pour le moment il est très bon contre
les plots mais pour être champion du
monde il faut être très bon contre
l'étape
donc si fait nul ici qu'il a fait nul nv
annuler caruana et battu les plots il
mériterait amplement d'y aller après
s'il fait nul sans poussette avec blanc
contre revel et qui perd au noir contre
caruana hockey faudra bien jouer sur les
deux dernières c'est comme ça
ça
il faut s'en sortir aujourd'hui et il va
à mon avis va le faire alireza
mai mais s'il y arrive pas ben ouais
enfin gérard bout d'un moment comme
dirait fable pour faire pour mériter dit
allez faut faire des choses un peu
spéciale de temps en temps
et faire nul contre caruana avec les
noirs c'est quelque chose de spécial
caruana dans ces situations là c'est un
joueur énorme on le sait même en méforme
i fé mal faire nul contre lui ici ce
serait une performance d'ali reza et sa
couronne est un superbe tournoi
car voilà qui est revenu qui s'assied
qui met la pression
en méforme nommé caruana est en méforme
apparaître un truc qui est vrai caruana
étaient 28 30 il ya un peu plus d'un an
il était clairement numéro deux mondial
il perd des points l'eau à chaque
tournoi il est au vif
on sait même pas comment il s'est
retrouvé là quoi toutes les parties les
mieux il faur cirad fin il s'est plu
caruana qu'on a connus numéro deux
mondial clair
soit il a régressé soyez pas en forme
depuis on en soit il est dans un moment
de doute ou je sais pas moi ce qui peut
arriver dans la vie perso de caruana et
c'est plus le grand caruana et malgré ça
ils continuent à se battre on l'a bien
vu aux candidats c'est pas c'est pas le
cas juana qu'on a connu dans le match de
championnat du monde contre carl scène
etc c'est un caruana et qu'on a trouvées
sur wii en fait ils sont ils ont voulu
envoyer une
une invitation à caruana ils sont allés
sur wii points comme ils ont ce caruana
qui est venu mais le caruana wish qui
fait mal
même qu'il a fait 6 6 dans un match du
championnat du monde contre carl scène
qu'il a gagné les candidats qu'il a
marché c'est lucas l'année sur weick
avec deux points et demi d'avancé sur la
concurrence fin c'est un monstre caruana
quand il est
en plein en pleine capacité de aux
pleins pouvoirs de ses capacités voilà
ils assoient régresser soyez dans une
mauvaise passe mais malgré ça il réussit
des seuils sba
le carreau nadine ya un an il a gagné
celle là à le carroi n'a en grande forme
cette position là tu dis que c'est déjà
à quasi terminé
expliqué lui même le colis des passés
par là il aime pas le game online ça
c'est sûr
cheetah doit il n'aime pas trop le
cheating lui non plus en physique plutôt
rapporte coville ils étaient plus
motivés intrinsèquement c'est top 3
mondial c'est top 2 mondial
intrinsèquement bruit slicks pas top 2
caruana spa top 3 c'est clair top 2 à
100%
wes knight qui l'a peut-être moins bien
gérée qui fait qu'ils en méforme peu
importe par la question
alireza évidemment avec les noirs
pour aller au candidat tu dois tenir
contre ce caruana c'est
s'y perd et ben il sera de nouveau dans
le groupe il sera toujours ce dans les
favoris à la qualif alireza mai mais
c'est normal qu'en perdant une partie
dans ce tournoi tu sois plus large
premier en mode a le mérite d'y aller
j'ai battu des mecs à 26,50 quoi il a
combien des lots le gars le plus fort
que ali reza est battu et c'est pas une
critique envers ali reza parce que c'est
la même chose pour fabiano et c'est la
même chose pour maximin donc c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas que cheyrou déjà le
joueur le plus fort qu'il est battu il
était 2666 alexandre prête que il est
combien au classement mondial
le joueur le plus fort qui est battu
alireza et les 68e mondial
bon
c'est quand même pas
c'est quand même pas l'exploit de
l'année quoi
ça doit être un peu près pareil
donc c'est un tournoi comme ça un petit
peu particulier
avec beaucoup de joueurs qui ont intégré
à cause du coc vider tous donc
évidemment ceux qui sont là en profite
maxime le joueur le mieux classé mondial
qu'il est battu c'est pavel pancrate of
donc c'est un tournoi spécial pour
mériter il faudra tenir tête aux
meilleurs mondiaux donc c'est caruana
c'est peut-être vite yougov ou quoi mais
il faudra faire une belle fin de tournoi
être bon dans le sprint maxime joueur le
mieux classé qu'il ait battu les 78e
mondial
il a 17 ans en même temps mais qu'ils
aient 18 ans ou 50 ans ça changera rien
en fait on parle pas de de l'âge de luxe
d'alireza c'est juste on parle de la
spécificité de ce tournoi où il manque
beaucoup de tops mondiaux
donc pour mériter d'aller au candidat il
faudra aussi faire un beau finish contre
les meilleurs c'est normal
on parle pas l'âge on parle d'une
performance dans un tournoi pour se
qualifier un autre tournoi donc que tu
es 80 ans 18 en deux ans ou 40 ça change
rien
les absents qui je suis les résultats
qui avait totalement raison bah oui il
ya beaucoup d'absents il ya beaucoup
d'absents donc
battre les jours à 26 50 27 il faut le
faire on voit que caruana et maxime ont
été moins efficaces qu ali reza pour le
faire et bravo ali reza qui a su saisir
les opportunités on se rappelle de sa
partie compte d'ailleurs où il a réussi
à pousser à bloc il a réussi à battre sa
chique irions avec les blancs assez
facilement donc bravo à lui il a il fait
le tournoi qui doit faire il ya ya ya
rien à dire maintenant il va falloir
aussi quand même tenir compte le top
mondial quoi
car si ce tournoi en théorie où il
aurait le droit de participer
c'est foutu n'en alireza s'il peut
perdre aussi ici fait nul disqualifie
s'y fait dro il ce quasi qualifié et s'y
perd il est en pleine course ça reste du
50-50
maxime maxime ça a l'air d'être assez
égale 1-1 égales
par le terme pour le moment aucun des
deux joueurs mal dessus
vraiment ça peut honnêtement ça peut
durer un certain moment
je n'avais encore le temps de séries
pour battre les meilleurs mondiaux à
hawaï alireza là c'est sûr car mon avis
dans prochain cycle des candidats déjà
ils devraient se qualifier assez
facilement s'ils se qualifient pas cela
à mon avis va se qualifier 1 mais si ce
qu'elle dit c'est pas ici se qualifiera
dans deux ans et à mon avis dans deux
ans il sera favori pour les gagner
c'est après un soin qui passe c'est top
situé deux ans les candidats pas tous
les ans et c'est tous les deux ans juste
là comme ça avait sauté une année avec
le co vides il y en aura encore l'année
prochaine mais sinon c'est tous les deux
ans
ça réfléchit
côté fabi
on ça réfléchit ça réfléchit ça peut
tant que pas mal de temps que tu es
fabiano ils aiment bien calculé en
profondeur
maxime a joué
fabiano a l'air assez serein mais
fabiano
sur h cinq cavaliers six mois soit qui
est proche 5 n'ont quand même
pas oublier que fabiano a connu déjà la
pression d'un match de championnat du
monde donc la pression il aboie un
fabiano
c'est clair qu'il souhaite pas faire
tomber cheyrou mais il faire tomber
fille rousse qui arrivera pas là fabiano
ce qu'il veut faire c'est utiliser son
temps
et maxime ça a l'air d'aller je le vois
pas perdre maxime
et à et quand il joue peut-être
surprendre alireza avec son coup paris
va pas jouer un coup pour le surprendre
à proprement dire mais peut-être qu'il
va le surprendre un moment donné firoud
dans son calcul qui aura que sept
minutes pour pour mettre à jour la
position et
si on retrouve cavaliers des 5
eca et des cinq peut-être le coup de la
turbine
nous on était sûr tour c 4
ça c'est l'idée ok ça ça doit être
turbine
avec fougue et 5 qui arrive
même qui a validé cinq sa force papillon
prend
ça comme ça
je suis pas sûr que ce soit si fort à
vrai dire
non
- qui est des cinq suivants j'arrive pas
content tu as vraiment prendre ici
vous est proposé ici dans le château
est ce que c'est vraiment bien ça
je suis pas sûr qu'il faille vraiment
jouer ça avec les avec les blancs
pas clair
pas sûr de cas et des 5 c est clairement
un coin
c'est clairement un coup après puisque
le tour c4 qui avait six tours prend ses
cinq proposés dans le chat est pas le
plus fort j'en sais rien
franchement je ne sais pas
je peux pas vous dire
les deux coups sont des options ça c'est
clair après lequel est le plus fort j'en
sais rien je
peux pas vous dire juste parce que je
sais pas et maxime maxime ça va jouer
il a joué roigé de antoine guiraud
ça fait un moment qu'on imaginait ce
projet 2
assurant finir par prendre
il veut faire tour c'est à mon avis tu
reprends des 4 et partir avec cavaliers
f6 et s'activer
à l'orangé de un peu mieux placé quoi
peut-être vouloir le mettre l'avancé
jusqu'en g3 même pour protéger un peu
c'est intéressant
parce que fabien n'aurait pas à jouer
j'ai l'impression que la pendue le ton
de côté alireza il envoie le cavalier
des think of habib
sy qu'avoir raison ça pour être termine
à dos
attention alireza
fabiano
prépa encore non c'est plus près pas mes
cavaliers des think of est malin il s'y
attendait pas en fait alireza il a tout
fait pour empêcher qui a aidé 5 il fait
pions prend bécade j'ai l'impression
fabiano va probablement enchaîné il
prend 1,7 on va voir les coûts arrivée
sur sur le petit écran nok et puis on
prend cavaliers prend il devrait y avoir
droit prend fou prend
et prendra prend fou prend
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que
l'ordinateur la turbine est la donne
plus d'eux parce qu'il pourra pas
reprendre du cavalier il ya cavaliers g5
et sur roy prend ça va être fou prend b
4 kg 5 et prend aussi ce goût ali reza
qui est peut-être en train de vaciller
ali reza qui est peut-être en train de
vaciller
alors là c'est le joueur le joueur
italien là qui fait mal
tiens allez prendre cette eau là ça va
arriver de partout
incroyable alireza à quelques encablures
de la ligne d'arrivée qui se fait
peut-être attrapé par le col
par fabiano caruana on sait terrible
piège estime qu il ya encore du contre
sur cinq au mais fou prend bécade fait
mal ou fou prend des quatre fait mal
le cavalier g5 sera d'autant plus
puissant le roi n'aura plus la case la
case cette
hausse a à l'ère de faire très mal et
attention à un caruana un gros des
partages ses adversaires ont marqué
beaucoup de points au cours du tournoi
il va revenir comme un boulet de canon
sur sur la concurrence alors qu'il était
presque au fond du trou 1 hier contre
grand délice avec les noirs il était
très mal le joueur américain
proche de faire annuler proche d'être
éliminés il y aller il a tout donné il
était mal contre séville encore la
veille et sur ces deux partis là il a
réussi à prendre un point et demi sur
deux quasiment on les volets le hold up
et là contre le numéro 1 du tournoi qui
semblait serein qui semblait tout
contrôler il est peut-être en train lui
montré pourquoi il était numéro deux
mondial pendant pendant tant d'années
fabiano ils montraient alireza encore le
gouffre qui le sépare du top mondial
c'est une partie importante 1 la vieille
garde contre la next gen
mais fabiano qui est peut-être en train
de s'imposer en patron
ce sera pas encore terminée viendrez qu
au coude à coude avec ali reza mir vient
de derrière avec l'aspiration
et il fait mal il fait mal fabiano la
confiance retrouvée
attention là est ce qu'il va trouver
tous les coups apparemment il ya que le
fou prend en b quattro qui fait qui fait
vraiment mal mais ça a l'air de faire
très mal fille round jackie et qui est
dans le dur alireza
face à face à ce monstre
il a envie d'y retourner au charbon
contre contre carl c'est nous contre eux
n'est peau il a envie de rejouer des
candidats fabiano il a envie d'y aller
il a envie de montrer sa vraie valeur de
montrer qu'ils pourraient être champions
du monde encore
malgré la trentaine
ils fonctionnent déjà résisté tienne
c'est un grand moment du tournant là
qu'on est en train de vivre
c'est énorme ce qu'il est en train de
réaliser
c'est énorme
allez on va voir on va voir si ali reza
réussi à m barbelés ou pas
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable ce qui
est en train de se passer mais le
scénario de la partie était pas top
après fabiano a raté beaucoup de
positions gagnantes
peut craquer encore aujourd'hui
ouais elle qui pourrait demain aller
chercher faire flotteurs montant sur
fabiano 1 effectivement maxime d'abord
avec les blancs pourrez
vous restaurer tir fabiano de la course
à son tour
on va voir on va voir fabiano qui doit
douter quand même il peut pas il peut
pas être et conflit peut pas être
confiant à 100%
peut il peut encore la rater six rounds
jacky doit s'accrocher
doit s'accrocher doit tout donner
c'est pas le fabiano de 2019 encore
moins celui de 2018 c'est le fabiano
2021 sa fabiano qui encore les
préparations qui réussit à se mettre
dans des bonnes positions mais qui a du
mal à conclure
il faut qu'ils jouent là-dessus a rallié
reza
il a un petit peu nerveux on sent qu'il
est nerveux
mais fabien ne trouve pas
facilement en tout cas l'option la plus
simple ça peu trop t1 toutes les
occasions ratées
paddy qui conclut encore fabiano
toute l'idée de
rezaï s'est sûrement cavaliers g5 roi
prend tout reprend tout reprend
cavaliers pros aussi s'il doit vouloir
revenir avec du cavalier c6 pour combler
les trous attaqué le pion est sûre f4
peut-être m leroy f 5 cavaliers prend g7
et peut-être 3g 4 pour aller chercher
les pions pour pour avancer il ya
peut-être des bars loutre ici cependant
ça sent difficile un roi j'ai capturé f5
peut-être 3g six cavaliers 6 3 et 5
car ailier g5 peut-être qu'ils espèrent
quelque chose comme ça et un blocus sur
carte blanche ça doit être l'idée de
défense d'ali reza ça quelque chose dans
ce style là peut encore espérer en tout
cas la turbine elle veut vraiment fou
prend des quatre absolument en premier
et sur cavaliers c6 du coup venir
installer ce fou en d6 et ne pas se
précipiter sur cavaliers g5 il ya
peut-être encore un petit peu de défense
tour h au 8
ça peut ça peut être tendu ça peut
encore être tendu est cependant en train
de regarder ce que donne la turbine est
cédé quatre des cinq cavaliers prend des
quatre
et ça peut être tendu il n'y a rien qui
ait fait faut jouer sur la fébrilité de
fabiano hier un moment donné qu'on
grandit lui s'il avait trois coups
droits un qui été complètement gagnant
inquiéter gagnant et l'autre qui
laissait vraiment revenir son adversaire
dans la partie ils avaient choisi le
mauvais détroit
c'est un moment tellement important la
de ce tournoi c'est peut-être un coup
décisif 1 pour la qualification
plus pour fabiano pour ali réserve qui
restera quand même en tête du tournoi
qui restera en gestion mais là c'est un
coup c'est un coût qui coûte cher
c'est un moment décisif
la nouvelle gare d'alireza le joueur en
forme le joueur en pente ascendante
celui qui sera sûrement l'adversaire de
magnus carlsen ou d'un autre d'ici
quelques années dont la route vers un
titre de champion du monde est déjà tout
tracé
et fabiano fabiano sur la pente
descendante il a perdu il a perdu un
match de championnat du monde contre
magnus il a réalisé des mauvais candidat
il est plus champion des états unis
c'est peut-être le rugissement du vieux
lyon
où l'anéantissement
et la continuité d'une longue chute dans
les abîmes du classement ah c'est
vraiment un moment important là pour les
deux hommes
c'est un moment très très important là
pour les deux hommes fabiano qui est
bien concentré et connaît l'importance
du coup qui va jouer là c'est vraiment
un coup
déterminant
qui pourrait quasiment changer la
trajectoire de sa carrière
ac c'est un moment c'est un moment
intense a envoy l'iresa qui essaye de se
détendre empli de stress
fabiano bien concentré
il un choix faire ici
va-t-il faire le bon ski alireza va
réussir à le faire déjouer à le faire
dérailler
quel combat les amis quel combat
il est complètement assis dans sa chaise
là il et il est prêt à bondir à lire les
calculs tous là il va essayer il va
essayer de mettre une accélération là
attention
attention la dd que dès que fabiano va
jouer là ça va partir côté alireza vous
allez voir anyresa là qui essaye
d'anticiper les coudes fabiano et voilà
il essaye vraiment sens on sent il est
concentré à 200% alireza il essaye
d'anticiper la décision de fabiano pour
réagir le plus vite possible et garder
un peu de temps il lui reste dix sept
quoi jouer plus de 6 minutes 40
s'est tendue s'est tendu
fabien noens un style caractéristique
qui bouge beaucoup ses mains
change souvent de position
et reste immobile après change un petit
peu de positions on a du mal à savoir
s'il va jouer les changements demain
alireza aussi les deux joueurs changent
de position
c'est terrible il ya un langage corporel
ya quelque chose qui se passe la table
numéro un
les deux bonhommes du tournoi là qu'ils
se rencontrent
fabiano dos au mur obligé de gagner
alireza en défense
ça réfléchit il peut se tromper il est
en train d'essayer d'évaluer
essaye d'évaluer les décisions là
fabiano est ce qu'il vaut mieux
commencer par prendre b4 pendant ses
huit ans voyait un cavalier ou g5
la ja il ya 3 3 options trois
possibilités nous on le sait il y en a
une qui est vraiment bonne c'est celle
du fou prend et le tour prend fou prend
et déjà un peu en dessous il faut il
vraiment qu'il hésite entre cavaliers g5
et fou prend b4 à mon avis il ya un bon
coup il ya un mauvais coup il va falloir
ouvrir la bonne porte
ils ne savent pas évidemment à les deux
joueurs
ils sont à du tout au courant
des bons coups des mauvais coups d
évaluation ils le savent les deux que
ces excès fabiano qui a la main dans
cette partie c'est lui qui mène c'est
lui qui met la pression ça les deux
joueurs le savent ils sont au courant
mais à quel point est il vraiment mieux
fabiano est il mieux dans toutes les
variantes y at il des possibilités
encore de défense pour ali reza cei ne
sont pas au courant ils ne le savent pas
et ils sont en train de tout donner pour
essayer l'un comme l'autre de trouver
soit la voie vers la victoire ou la voie
vers les barbelés pour ali reza dans ses
22 mètres un petit peu comme le stade
toulousain il ne veut pas laisser passer
son adversaire
seul fou prend b4 semble vraiment
fonctionné mais alors là pour le
comprendre en partie c'est compliqué
parfois c'est un petit peu un jeu de
pile ou face aux siens
enfin bien aux tirs change de position
c'est pas s'il va jouer pas jouer
à la tension est palpable a dit reza qui
a besoin de souffler un c'est ça la
difficulté quand on a peu de temps aussi
fabiano joue par rafales et alireza est
vraiment obligé d'être en concentration
maximale pendant plus d'une heure et
demie deux heures l'un dans cette partie
j'ai envie de dire même avec le début de
partie va avoir quatre heures de
concentration maximum il va pas falloir
flanché pour le jeune joueur français
lassés on voit même mc ses pieds si vous
observez bien les pieds d'alireza le
stress est elle la fatigue est telle que
les pieds ne bouge plus en fait ouais ça
y est ça repart mais c'est un petit peu
comme une pile un moment donné ça
s'arrête ya plus la même vitesse et ça
c'est la fatigue mentale et physique qui
s'installent pour ali reza
mêmes même sont même son mouvement de
pied de penser ralenti même son niveau
de stress n'est n'est plus à 100% et sa
part qu alger 5 c'est la faute c'est la
faute
fabiano qui se trompent
fabiano qui se trompent les amis au
sahara moments forts on l'a senti on l'a
vécu ensemble au sein moment c'est un
moment club charles assad ça tourne
peut-être complètement faveur d'ali reza
fabiano qui a pris la môme décision il
ne le sait pas encore mais peut-être qui
vient de perdre la qualification des
candidats ce moment
il remet il remet une pause après roy g6
mais apparemment fabiano c'est raté
le chant du cygne ça chante ça chante le
signe
il s'est complètement planté alireza il
reprend confiance là on sent il est bien
dans quel point aussi ça va pas passer
ça pour pour fabiano ils
ne le sait pas encore mais il est déjà
dans le dur fabiano allez on va voir si
encore un moment difficile pour ali reza
may alireza cas de nouveau toutes les
cartons jeu
on l'a peut-être vécu ensemble ce moment
décisif un vraiment le moment décisif la
à à 16 heures heure française 17h heure
de riga le cavalier j'estime qu'au qui
part qui change tout la physionomie du
tournoi et toute la physionomie de la
partie
le joueur américain qui flanche comme
tous les jours mais c'est pas grande et
luce en face aujourd'hui ça devrait
tenir côté alireza les mouvements de qui
ont repris à regarder c'est incroyable
la psychologie aux échecs
ali reza est content du cavalier g5 je
pense qu ali reza b le fourbe et quattro
est de son côté
en sang qui reprend confiance et fabiano
après roy g6 qui tentent immédiatement
aux ja
il ya un problème côté fabiano king5
roigé si c'est pas normal de retenter du
temps
ouais ça ça a tourné là ça a tourné sa
tournée clairement
sa tournée clairement
c'est le temps de le temps de réflexion
n'est pas n'est pas normal le clic n'est
pas n'est pas au rendez vous
ça craque
ils n'y arrivent plus fabiano dans les
moments importants dans les moments
décisifs il n'est plus aussi tranchants
et la lame non n'aiguise est ne suffira
pas à scalper le joueur français
à lire et zafy rogers on va faire un
tout petit tour juste sur l'échiquier de
maxime pour voir ce qu'il en est en
vitesse
oui ça peut en tournée aussi pour
l'autre joueur français mvl hausse est
chaude partout
elle qui peut qui peut clutch indiqué
mme les deux puntos hausse est peut-être
en train de tourner côté français des
deux côtés 1 on va rester quand même là
sur ce moment important fabiano caruana
encore man
dans ses pensées ont muré dans ses
pensées j'ai envie de dire mais qu'est
ce que ces étranges cavaliers g5 qui
paroisse g6 tempo et fabiano qui tente
de nouveau
il est pas dans il n'est pas dans fabi
il est pas dedans
et 35 minutes
ça s'est senti la fabiano qui est en
train de en train de mollir
on al impression qu avait jugé cinq rois
d'ici là il a eu un éclair qui lui a dit
qu'il s'était trompé parce que
normalement rouages et si si tu as
commencé qu'à et g5 sais que tu as les
coûts
je sais je sais pas ce qu'il a imaginé
moi j'ai six étaient forcés il y avait
ni roi 8 miroir miroir g8 ni roi et
fuite s'il avait tout reprend donc je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé car j'ai
cinq 3g si c'est eux c'est pas le bon
rythme tu dois pas faire ça
c'est quelqu'un qui avait juste 3g si
c'est un roi roi sur la huitième c'était
tout reprend tour donc le fait sur roy
g6 de bloquer la seaco logiquement
fabiano fait une énorme erreur ici
pourquoi ne pas laisser à son adversaire
les réflexions aller partent sur ton
prend ses huit maintenant
alors là il ya deux coups pour ali reza
cavaliers prend ou hutus reprend
on va voir ce qu'ils décident
cavale et prend c'est un peu bizarre la
tour est mal placé ensuite on va la
ramener et il doit vouloir cavaliers
prend ensuite le 6 par la suite
c'est curieux ans qui va te faire
fabiano achetant que j'ai pas compris on
voit là on aurait dû petit hashtag
ensuite en réalité le seul toit l'iresa
qui prend quand même son temps attention
il ya quand même la pression à côté ali
reza et wii prend de la tour il vient
prendre la colonne ouverte alireza
et cavaliers prend aussi ce tempo
vraiment le rythme de fabiano n'est pas
normal contre sens
da contre sens maintenant on va voir un
nous on avait les coûts de turbines
cavaliers prend 1,6
maintenant la turbine donne cavaliers
ces six f4 à voilà et c'est la variante
qu'on avait vu avec la turbine tout à
l'heure avec les pions qui sont bloqués
sur cases noires 1 le foot cases noires
qui peut pas aider à pousser
ça a pas l'air d'aller du tout côté côté
fabi
vraiment une erreur de jugement et
d'estimations la position les pions
n'avance pas les pions sont bloqués et
le fou ne peut pas intervenir le pion
d'alireza va partir en asymco et fabiano
ne pourra plus mettre la marche avant
c'est incroyable ce que vient de faire
fabiano a les focales iresa juge bien
maintenant de toute façon qu'avait
laissé si ces forces et ça défend le
pion y'a pas d'autres coups ça va partir
c'est le cas des lycées si ce qui par il
ali reza je pense que c'en est fini pour
fabiano et le cavalier qui par an ces
six ans et a annoncé les amis et y'a
plus rien pour fabiano incroyable
les espoirs américains douchez la france
les amis
olga et qui est parti en c6 royal et
sharp qui part il ya les sharp qui
étaient là elles n'attendaient que ça
les amis on attendait que ça les amis je
crois qu'on est bien là je crois qu'on
est bien
les américains douchez ils sont pas bien
les caries ils sont pas bien auront-ils
un joueur aux candidats dans dans six
mois je ne pense pas je ne pense pas les
amis
on n'est pas bien là il est pas bien mon
famille à il est passé de joueur italien
joueurs américains en quelques coups
c'est terrible
c'est terrible il n'a pas les trois
bonnes couleurs
ils sont ils il est pas bien y'a plus
rien en fait y'a plus rien f4 les pions
n'avancerons jamais le fouet pour am et
on fout et pourra frérot
son fouet pour avis les amis
ah bah là il va rien faire il va rien
faire le fou des deux il est bloqué
qu'est ce que c'est mal joué de la part
de fabiano
de fabiano quand même il a complètement
déjoué
alors qu'il était complètement
alireza été complètement à sa merci et
fabiano qui a qui a déjoué au pire
moment pour lui hélas alireza maintenant
c'est la voie royale en nul demain avec
les blancs nuls à la dernière avec les
noirs ne sera peut-être même pas
nécessaire
fabiano qui a très mal calculé c'était
une variante de quatre coups forcé et
n'a pas été capable de la calculer il a
dû penser cavaliers f4 roi f5 cavaliers
prend h cinq cavaliers des prend aux
cinq cavaliers pranger set il a dû
penser à quelque chose comme ça mais
après roigé six cavaliers e6 il a
peut-être oublié cavaliers f3 fourchette
qui gagne le fou en d2 est ce que c'est
ça que fabiano a raté peut-être
peut-être peut-être que c'est cette
variante quelque part qu'il a mal jugé
qui sait en tout cas il ya une faute de
calcul côté côté fabiano elle coûte cher
elle coûte cher cette faute
il envoie f k coût mais là il est
complètement bloqué je pense qu'il ya
vraiment plus grand risque pour pour ali
reza à moins d'un choc
ça sent bon le lait blanc pourront plus
passer sur case blanche
il n'y a plus vraiment de problème
autant il reste que 14 qu à jouer c'est
pas une position si difficile que ça il
va envoyer un petit ali sahin petit à
petit asymco alireza
et ça devrait passer
yanni l'enfance après wife 5 kg 7,3 g
6/4
6/3 6/1 gamia kg 5 encore
ça peut jouer ça encore
axim
ça va jouer le gars à côté maxime
je vous ai dit quand il ya eu le fou
prend des cas je vous ai dit que c'était
un moment un moment clutch je vous mets
rarement sur les lives on fait pas comme
sur les live américain inventé de l'aed
quand il y en a pas un
on n'invente pas de hype comme mia r ça
sentait vraiment le moment clutch du
tournoi
et on dit owen ce serait fantastique de
jouer well pour maximin c'est tellement
un plot
howell c'est vraiment le plot ultime et
en plus si la couleur correspondante
ce serait magnifique comme résultat ça
pour maxime owen n'a aucune chance
contre la nouvelle je l'annoncent
owen n'a aucune chance contre les
nouvelles
ce serait le penalty mais alors rêver
c'est punto instant tu
peux être si vous voulez hein ça il est
très sympa de la vidéo il n'y a pas de
problème mais c'est le foot aux
instances en fait aux ailes aux blancs
pour maxime cepoun tôt
il n'y a pas de souci
à ce niveau de la compétition jouer
david noël c'est un cadeau enfin vous
n'imaginez même pas une place au
candidat contre david wells un cadeau
penalty sans gardien
ouais ce serait magnifique
ce serait vraiment magnifique
il peut y avoir dupé non il peut y avoir
du péno demain qui se présentent maxime
qui est bien on va retourner quand même
sur le chéquier d'alireza tension
alireza plus de 3 45
attention les amis attention
ali reza est passé proche
proche du coup
mais attention de ne pas se reposer sur
nos lauriers il reste plus que 3 30 ans
aux joueurs français ça peut encore
tourner de manière négative il faut pas
craquer en maintenant il a toutes les
cartes entre ses mains alireza fabiano
la laisser revenir dans la partie lui a
fait un cadeau maintenant il faut pas
lui rendre la pareille
il va falloir
réussir à serrer la vis sans coup férir
il ya quand même du stress 5 août ali
reza i c'est qu'il est plus perdants
mais c'est pas encore fait et du coup ya
peut-être de la pression qui remonte un
c'est qu'il est passé proche de la
correctionnelle
le joueur français
né à présent il a une pression qui est
tout autre c'est celle de ne pas
gaspiller l'annulent de ne pas pourrir
sa position tout seul
ça c'est une pression qui est aussi
difficile à supporter il envoie roi f5
donc ils provoquent car à l'étranger
cette
jouer instantanément par fabiano
il va repartir avec le ronge et 6
attention hein là c'est maintenant lui
qui prend du temps peut-être pas à bon
escient alireza
il reprend du temps à la pourtant qu'il
prend juste at il l'avait il revient à
laisser bon le cavalier qui va revenir
aux six
façons il est obligé
n'a pas d'autres coups quoique il doit
peut-être regarder un os 6 on l'a vu
nous sur la caméra
que le roi rené à angers 6 lecavalier
qui va revenir en os 6 3 et 5 et
cavaliers g5
qui va donner le pion mais pour pour
avoir énormément d'activités un cavalier
qui part en c5
ça lui a permis d'activer son roi en
fête et de s'octroyer la casse et 5 pour
son cavalier
comme ça après cavaliers 6 3 et 5 si le
cavalier par angers 5 alireza va pouvoir
jouer cavalier ses cinq
tours b1 et a5 et iri l'imaginent comme
ça qui va réussir à faire un blocus sur
casse blanche et après jouer cavalier 7
qui a aidé 5/4 lycées trois peut-être
même jouer le gain
donc fabiano va devoir réfléchir à
prendre là nul ici carballo 6-3 f5 et
ici peut-être que fabiano va accepter la
nulle et essayer de gagner demain avec
les noirs
à ses bouillants les amis mais peut-être
que meilleures décisions pratiques pour
fabiano ses cavaliers g7 ici et accepter
d'avoir raté le gain ont assez difficile
en dans la tête à mon avis pour fabiano
ils laissent pas transférer ses émotions
mais ça doit bouillir à l'intérieur
il sait qu'il a raté un énorme avantage
aujourd'hui
la ceni sion difficile à prendre pour
fabiano il peut jouer cavalier g5 et la
force et en sachant qui prend plus de
risques qu'autre chose où il peut jouer
cavalier g7 et se dire je mets tous
demain avec les noirs contre un joueur
plus faibles et moins expérimenté et il
fait cavalier chez 5
auquel moment incroyable encore dans ce
dans cette partie fabiano qui met all-in
fabiano qui donne tout cas ils c5 qui
par
fabiano qui décide de tout mettre sur
celle là
bon alors là c'est intense les amis il
met tout là-dessus immisce tous les amis
me disaient ils me sont aux dhimmis
agadji mais sa cb il a tout mis fabiano
il va tout tenter il va tout risquer
pour essayer d'aller déstabiliser
alireza y faire vaciller dans le night
note
c'est incroyable ça on s'y attendait pas
vraiment pensé fabiano pedneault qui
allait prendre la nulle accepté de
s'être trompée accepté de repartir avec
le demi point repartir au charbon demain
mais non fabiano la marque des grands
joueurs
malgré une méforme malgré le fait qu'il
soit derrière dans cette partie veut
tout donner il veut se battre maintenant
ici aujourd'hui
c'est un immense moment les amis
alireza
bien concentré il sait qui peut
carrément gagner ce qualifier ce soir
ali reza mais il peut aussi tout perdre
il peut tout perdre aussi
c'est incroyable je m'y attendais
vraiment pas
c'est écrit perdre fabiano j'en sais
rien ou alors l'audace sourit aux
audacieux la chance sourit aux audacieux
j'en sais rien les amis
quelle réaction d'orgueil du champion
américain
ce qui va tenter cavaliers recettes on
dit dans le tchat avec l'idée de mettre
le karayan d63 eu six cavaliers des 6 et
essayer d'envoyer les douches puntos
on a peine au 30e coup 31 minutes pour
fabiano 3,25 pour ali reza
quel combat les amis
quel combat
lire les à kia qui a dû quand même
espérer voir la nulle pour pour fabiano
même si c'est qui peut gagner à ces deux
grands champions qui s'affrontent ici
c'est magnifique
ces deux immenses champions
face à face
le futur alireza celui qui ne veut pas
s'avouer encore vaincu et qui veut
montrer
qu'il est à son cadet qu'il est encore
le battrons le boss du circuit
lorsque carl scène est absent
ça va être ça va être bouillant ça va
être bouillant les amis cette fin de
partie
c'est cette note qui n'est pas encore
finie cette pression qui monte qui est
en train de culminer
peut-être un quart
atteint maintenant pour fabiano ou tour
b 1 ce sont les deux coups candidat
il faut pas avoir envie d'aller aux
toilettes un quota l'iresa trois minutes
il n'a pas le temps là il faut la petite
bouteille sous l'habile tas au cas où
et on sent que ces moments sont
importants qu'est ce qu'elle est
important de cette partie pour la
carrière des deux joueurs
j'ai envie de dire que la belle histoire
se serait que ça tourne en faveur d'ali
reza mais attention
fabien autié stressant il bouge ses
mains tu as tout le temps l'impression
qui va jouer
va pas tirer de plans sur la comète
ouais c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
ça peut être une son pouvoir un passage
de relais exactement
à la tension est palpable prend là c'est
un beau moment de sport dans les a mis
là on ressent la pression vraiment on
l'a on la ressent la pression un fou
là c'est chaud là c'est chaud
pas le droit à l'erreur ni d'un côté ni
de l'autre les deux ont vraiment envie
de l'emporter ali reza qui a qui n'a pas
tremblé ans quand il a vu que fabiano
allait jouer le gain il a tout de suite
envoyé le cavalier ans et 5 c'était son
idée
pas de coup de surprise pas de coup de
peur ils étaient prêts au combat
j'essaie de se détendre un petit peu là
ça va être dur un lacet des moments
intenses à vivre c'est des bons moments
à vivre là pour les joueurs c'est un
temps c'est stressant mais c'est des
moments dont on se rappelle tout une
villa qui sont en train de passer
emotionnellement sas a rempli une
personne ne sait vraiment il ya vraiment
beaucoup de choses qui se passent dans
la tête au niveau au niveau de la
confiance concentration l'intensité cdc
des énormes moment à passer
fabiano qui reste absolument impassible
il a gaffé il a perdu son avantage mais
pas une grimace pas un signe il reste
concentré comme toujours il reste au
combat c'est vraiment incroyable
alireza on voit qu'il est mieux
si on pour maxime serait pas une
mauvaise opération david howell qui
l'emportent maxime qui pourrait flotter
sur orwell ce serait la good news
surtout qu'en cas de nul ici ça laisse
vraiment toutes les options à maxime
va peut-être prendre là nul on va aller
jeter un petit coup d'oeil à l'échiquier
numéro 200 tonnes dira rocchi qui
réfléchit on est au 31e coup
parce qu à l ol qui fait tomber korobov
c'est vraiment une très bonne nouvelle
honnêtement
ouais je pense que son rêve c'est une
nulle de fil rouge à aujourd'hui et
jouer firoud demain qui aurait besoin
que d'un nul pour se qualifier
chercher un demi point je pense qu'il en
veut pas plus la victoire de l'ol fait
vraiment du bien à tout le monde
dans le tournoi
c'est peut-être l'alignement des
planètes pour les deux français et six
caruana vassy aujourd'hui contre contre
phil rogers il sera peut-être même bon à
prendre demain pour maxime au blanc
les a alertés en train de faire le taf
la presse pas bhl
favi en pleine réflexion
aïe c'est vraiment raté un nombre ait
note
ça a réfléchi la fabiano il sait pas
trop quoi faire
c'est perdu
c'est raté il sait rater fabi c'est raté
sa menace pas eu 6
il doit calculer un peu aussi sway mais
bon cavalier jump caïds et roanne on
sait qu'on est tous rue 8 en fait on va
le choper le pion vêtements tout
bêtement
ça va faire un nul 1 1 chez maxim on va
aller suivre ça en direct et on va
revenir sur ce design note
maxime qui s'est levé qui est reparti
sur tomber 3
ouais ça va faire nul côté maxime
cavalier à vii jouer c'est parti côté
alireza le combat reprend le cavalier
qui par un f-16 dont il veut cavaliers
des six échecs fourchette ali reza qui
va probablement jouer droit aussi ce qui
va l'aider si c'est la tour qui va
partir et ça va partir avec les douches
pour une poche
les pointages qui vont partir attention
ils tentent d'envoyer le spawn tosh
si tu vas voir la fourchette ça c'est
sûr ludwig
la question c'est ce qui va réussir à
tenir dix coups ici
position n'est pas simple
c'est très très tendue
voilà on ressent on ressent la pression
là c'est le stress
la pression est palpable à lire et zaki
qui est concentrée fabiano aussi un même
sur le temps d'aller rezaï donne tout il
calcule il doit vouloir enchaîner les
coups ali reza qui s'apprête à jouer roy
aussi ce qui par c'était un peu le seul
coup dans tous les cas la normale en ces
cavaliers des systèmes pos je suis
étonné que ça je vous parle en poil plus
vite sur ces coups là
parce que roy au sis au final il va pas
répéter avec cavaliers g5 ce serait
complètement con à moins qu'ils
veuillent nul et si tu as décidé de
jouer ces cavaliers des 6 1
cahill et c'est incroyable ça qu'on
revient on revient au même donc ces
cavaliers des six
tours cac par f5 et ça envoie les pions
1 et x 4 et ça va envoyer deux partout
il ya des cahiers des 3 qui arrive c'est
le bordel mais à vrai dire car il y
avait trois ou six étaient quasi forcée
je suis étonné de voir caler des
systèmes pos et f5 tempo pour essayer de
mettre sous pression alireza mai mais
c'est tout bénef
ils hésitent à prendre l'annulerait mais
c'est un peu con en fait le timing
encore c'est que si tu hésites apprendre
la nulle prends ta décision la cites a
essayé de faire biffer kfc à trois aussi
ces cas et j'ai cinq échecs mais au
moins quand tu fait cavaler 7 3 au 6
juin cavalli des 6 es tu joues le gain
fawcett décide avant quoi
et maxime qui signe là nul on nous dit
ça va signer probablement
qu'on fait là si tu joues tu donnes à
vrai dire un temps de 1 tendre et pire
tu donnes un temps de répit
à voir la nuit en direct en tonnes qui
la prends c'est pas un mauvais résultat
pour maxime
voilà ça c'est la bonne nouvelle pour
maxime nul tranquille avec les noirs
ça réfléchit côté ma il me
dit allez on va rester sur la partie
d'alireza
il ya d'autres résultats qui sont qui
sont tombés
pas encore wheadon cowell qui a battu
korobov
ça c'est dans les parties importantes en
haut de en haut de tableau
voilà on la voit en direct nul signé
chez maxim avec les noirs bons résultats
maxime qui aura les blancs probablement
demain
et qui pourra aller aller chercher la
gagne
et reprendre la place qui lui est due à
l'est on va rester
sur fabiano
il faudra absolument gagner demain pour
maxime en revanche
pouvoir gagner demain avec les blancs
on est bien jeter un oeil à 2007 sanchez
achats se résolvent pour bien voir les
tables on attend le coup de fabiano ici
ce moment très important pour le tournoi
mais pour moi dans les joueurs à 5
ennemis en fait il que des nuls
et il ya que owen qui a gagné donc c'est
très très bien pour maxime et une nulle
de witte yougov
contre
contre shirov
nul d'eau par ina et maximy a toutes les
chances du monde qui réussissent à
choper howell au blanc
c'est absolument parfait pour pour
maxime
c'est absolument parfait
maxime qui n'aura plus qu'à battre ol au
blanc et faire nul au noir à la dernière
et ça devrait passer
forcément alireza
je n'ai pas nous casser le moral dans le
chat
ne venez pas nous casser le moral
c'est vrai en plus que c'est sûr qu'ils
jouent ali reza
mais c'est pas sûr [ __ ] c'est sûr
qu'ils veulent les réserver aux quelle
horreur
à quelle horreur venez vous casser le
moral dans le chat les gars maintenant
si orange ou alireza c'est la cata
pascal iresa s'il a besoin que de drouot
en fait ils vadrot et du coup le plot va
continuer à avancer quoi ah mais maxime
va jouer aux ailes à la dernière au
magnifique magnifique magnifique
magnifique howell aura aura les blancs
et maxime vaval battre à la dernière
ombre ce magnifique très bonne nouvelle
en réalité petit trot demain de l'ol
contre ali reza
encore mieux encore mieux pour l'
excellente nouvelle tour g8 attention ça
à partir avec f sinko
ou attention au roi des think of wef
quatre cavaliers detroit c'est la ligne
dont on parle et on rentre pris pieds et
poings liés dedans
là je suis pas content la turbine donne
un cavalier e quattro sortie des enfers
avec un cavalier promeut en cavalier
cissé chaque croix c5 et cavaliers pros
g8
mais qu'est ce que c'est compliqué les
amis il ya cavaliers prend 1,5 à présent
fou prend aux cinq cavaliers f3 roi f2
cavaliers prend 1,5 et cavaliers f6 la
ligne est complètement forcés
et les noirs on a cinq
cavaliers prend 1 h 5 baies 5 ab à
quatre pions prend b3 pro cette ligne
d'enfoirés et le pion est inarrêtable
ça tiendrait sur le ils
fabiano qui a joué roigé de il a
peut-être vu ans il a peut-être vu tout
ça et il envoie roi
g27 ligne de ouf avec le a5b 5 à 4 baies
et il fait froid je 2 pour anticiper il
a dû la voir cette ligne fabiano elle
était très linéaire
c'était très linéaire il a dû voir tout
ça et jouffroy g2 ils temporisent il
laisse les choix à faire à ali reza il
va falloir faire les bons choix ici il
donne pas la variante force et
ils réussissent pas ouvrir sa bouteille
d'eau quand même terrible des images
terribles du coût de la chemise ça
marche les mains glissent ça veut dire
que les mains sont moites les moins sont
moites côté côté fabiano
il ne reste rien paraître mais issue
en l'assurant l'empêché d'ouvrir la
bouteille d'eau
les mains sont très très loin de là les
mains sont très très moite il ne laisse
rien paraître mais il laisse
transparaître des gouttes de sueur
ça suit partout il reste deux minutes
ali reza i rèss lui coup c'est une
encore une grosse décision à prendre
est-ce qu'il va prendre en b3 ici le
pion et peut-être emprise mais il y
avait cinq échecs il faut calculer c'est
compliqué et ce qui va anticiper avec
trois des cinq
îles et il est pas sûr ils hésitent
alireza qu'essaye de se reconcentrer la
tête changer d'avis
c'est encore un moment important au sac
lunch dans tous les sens
sans la pression ali reza qui vient de
changer d'avis la ferme qui movement est
là il a fait un petit mouvement
peut-être le joueur français
oc l'hésitation là
attention ne faut pas faire une ailleurs
c'est pas le moment
c'est pas le moment allez allez alireza
avec confiance avait confiance il va
envoyer le roi des saintes le roi des
saints qui part c'était la ligne numéro
un
il ya eu un moment d'hésitation terre
est bien pour ali reza mais il sait s'en
est bien sorti et c'est cool parce que
il n'ya pas de cavalier quatre cavaliers
f6 c'est contrôler
et le roi sac il
y avait des f-5 sa menace pas la
fourchette on recettes
en plus si gehrig demain s'il ne perd
pas pardon si fait nul demain c'est
howell aux blancs france est quasiment
un péno blanc il peut même tenter de le
battre tout en sachant qu'une nul doit
doit amplement lui suffire
vidéo elle c'est vraiment le péno
absolue moi je pense qu'il va le battre
en vrai demain au blanc
c'est en fait c'est une très bonne
nouvelle ce david howell qui gagne
en fait c'est magnifique en fait c'est
magnifique
nulle et demain battre ol ça ne lui fait
pas peur
ah oui vous dit wade doit absolument
avoir les noirs à huy et alireza doit
faire gaffe à voir des noirs aussi pour
pas avoir trois les blancs ça peut faire
une vélo elle dans cette histoire doit
elle est une tellement bonne décision
une tellement bonne
nouvelle
c'est magnifique c'est magnifique tout
se passe très bien les amis
ses routes chat peut même la gagner mais
si firoud djia gagne c'est la voie
royale
non vraiment la décision là
le résultat est le résultat rêvé
bon sinon c'est bon signe à tout se
passe très bien aujourd'hui la seule
chose qui pourrait
mettre un grain de sable dans de cette
magnifique mécanique ce serait une
victoire de fabiano
mais il semble être à contre sens
là fabien nury là il a l'air d'être
complètement perdu
l'air du temps il y aurait six coups
anyresa qui fait vraiment une bonne game
fabiano qui s'est perdu en vrai à vrai
dire un
facile et il est visuellement il est
bien fabi mais il a même un pion de plus
mais le problème c'est qu'il peut jamais
mettre la marche avant ils sont fous et
un plot et après à 5 au prochain il
pourra plus jamais avancer cette masse
de pions
et en fait s'il n'arrive pas à avancer
c'est dur qu'est ce qu'il a joué aux
familles il a mis la tour en b1 c'est un
aveu de faiblesse tombé 1
c'est un aveu faiblesse tour b 1
et oui il joue à hercules hercules
fabiano maintenant il ya think oaa sinko
ou pas oui asymco
asymco pour sécuriser le pion
à la lire et zaki est sur un nuage
depuis le début du tournoi il faut que
ça continue
mais la vrai dire il n'y a plus vraiment
d'idée pour
pour fabiano pasquet f5 il l'aura jamais
le pion aux 5es trop surveillé
hikaru va bien comme le plus logique oui
enfin il caroit aussi dit caprica et des
cinq sets gagnants pour qu'à roanne avec
la partie était terminée un donc on va
quand même faire gaffe avec les
commentaires des quarts ou les amis
laval yeux 4 attention coup un peu
bizarre qui avait lieu 4 ça enlève la
pression sur le pion b3
attention c'est un peu bizarre
visuellement alors il veut se donner la
montée du roi
alors c'est peut-être très bien joué un
petit sourire ligne de l'ordi possible
je sais pas j'ai pas j'ai pas d'ordi
assez puissant
il veut re qu'à 3 des 3,5 fois triple
tranchant c'est la triple l'âme
d'un côté ça lui permet de rentrer dans
la position mais ça enlève la pression
sur sur b3 et si le roi se fait chasser
ça peut donner l'entrée du roi blanc et
le rouge proche
mais auquel s'adonnent roi des trois
rois c'est de roy prend et l'option qui
pousse aussi un
c'est un coup c'est le coup on va dire
le plus tranchant et maintenant il veut
cavaliers aux sept cavaliers f5 ou la
ruine ans a l'air fort en fait
ah oui en fait ça a l'air d'être bien
joué à première vue c'est pas le coup
qu'on avait
mais ça a l'air d'être cool
ordi propose à 5 à 5 coups très logique
pour les blancs en fait ça empêche à 5
des noirs
et suroît des trois tours b 2
ok ça assez logique à 5 une fois qu'on
l'a vu mais je pense pas que ce sera
jouée en fait les noirs ils veulent à
cinq cavaliers 7 car il y avait 5 3 des
trois rois ces deux essais juste
complètement gagnant le fou est un plot
et et les noirs rendre sur toutes les
cases blanches
la partie va se décider maintenant de
toute façon
un clairement à 5 en fait c est logique
as
5 vous prend et ça tu es content parce
que ça active ton fou avec les blancs ça
serait une excellente nouvelle pour les
blancs mais à
[Musique]
ce prix-là pas commencer par à 5 à main
sur à 5 d'alireza your wife 3 yapluka
valeo 4 peut pas tout faire aux et
chacun
las chance pour famille de continuer à
mettre la pression c'est à 5 en fait
sinon c'est hyper fort pour pour ali
reza ça rentre vraiment de partout sur
case blanche il a toutes les cases
blanches en vrai
wade trois
fous 1 pour couper
deux peut-être pour avancer et détroit
les deux
jean guy qui gagne qui revient à 6
attention à liu yang et peut être
dangereux ça c'est bon encore pour le
départage d'alireza
cavaliers 4 il met la pression sur
fabiano la maintenance et une partie à
trois résultats
il peut la perdre alireza mais fabiano
peut la perdre aussi
s'ils gagnent maintenant alireza il
termine le tournoi ainsi ali riza la
gagne
60 jours à ce probablement howell demain
et ils nul suffira
ce sera terminé
il a joué tour c'est un je crois fabiano
et maintenant ça va partir sur du roi
des trois-rois eu 2 et d3 d2 et les
pions vont partir de l'autre côté c'est
tellement serré
c'est tellement serré les amis
j'espère qu ali reza on n'a pas trop me
et qu'il a les nerfs pour la jouer celle
là parce que c'est une partie très
importante elle est plus du tout en
contrôle 1 là il est plus en contrôle y
donne tout il veut contrer
et sajoo 3 résultat ici
il n'a pas joué la variante la plus safe
il a joué la variante pour pour mettre
fabiano sous pression
c'est peut-être très bien joué c'est
peut-être très mal joué le résultat
malheureusement
donnera l'analyse normalement il
faudrait pas mais ça va être un peu ça à
vrai dire tu as tellement difficile de
juger la sicile a pris la bonne décision
ou pas
en tout cas il a pris une décision
courageuse
et fléchit l'estrie c'est il a vu le roi
des trois à l'ailé va se décider il
encore une quarantaine de secondes à il
a le temps il ya trente secondes par
coup s'est retiré sept coups mais là
c'est assez linéaire ainsi fait roi des
trois fous endroit eux deux les coûts
cédé 3 des deux ça joue tout seul
attention ne pas tomber quand même petit
coup derrière la pendule il a bien fait
plus que 28 secondes allez il faut
prendre la décision
d'un des petit coup d'oeil attention ne
pas tomber il était tombé contre magnus
carlsen roi des trois qui est parti là
normalement pour fab il faut faire un
fou un tempo c'est fait faut pas perdre
de temps on est obligé de continuer à
noter les coups alors ce qui à trente
secondes de rage ou les joueurs sont
obligés de noter après que ça a été joué
ils n'ont pas le droit de jouer tempo il
faut noter le coup donc qui note est là
maintenant re 2 e 6 ça va être la
variante ça va partir
personne ne sait si ça marche ou pas
quel courage d'alireza d'aller là dedans
il se fait confiance il fait confiance
le français
+ 18 secondes il va devoir jouer une
façon ça par endroits à eux deux la
variante est quasiment forcé un
fabiano qui boit un petit coup ça peut
traduire de l'inquiétude
c'est rentré là où il le voulait
sa clique un sa clique
ce que 6 des trois f 5
qu'est ce que ça donne
tours 8 peut-être chez 4 pourquoi j'ai
trois à geroy g3
avaler des cas 3 pranger 4 c'est
extrêmement complexe
la l'ordi donnent gagnant pour les noirs
après carré lisse et de mme émond
tellement dur et tellement dur
tellement dur
ça serait payant pour les noirs alors
après est ce qu'après aussi c'est aussi
touré fuite qui est jouable pour
empêcher la poussée
est ce que là les blancs auraient un
asymco
détroit et à 6
ça c'est turbine est ça gagne donc sur à
5 faudrait jouer à 6
c'est trop compliqué il faut être deux
des trois tours un roi des deux essais
ultra complexe il ya autant de
possibilités
en profondeur 40 40 gagnant ici huawei
met fin aux caisses et
touahri fit en france et 6
6 3 il fit pour procès
6b prend fou prend b4
détroit
au faou prend effet dès 2e set d1 dames
et à papeete ses huit dames sur échec
cavalli évidemment mesdames sur l'échec
ça fait mal ça
aussi ce fait mal alors si tu aurais
fuite ya tout reprend ses six vous prend
et que ça gagne avec le jauge puntos
hausse et salsa et donc ça veut dire que
tous réfutent tout reprend qui on prend
fou prend tour bouge f 5 e 3f 6 ha non
et si ça va faire tout ça c'est g4
surmontions prend au roi prend des deux
vous prendrez de roy prend d2 et h5 et
punto cht
ça
ok vous dites que c'est gagnant donc je
trouve mais
ça c'est incroyable
non mais ça il va pas voir
après eux 6 tu peux jouer et tout
reprend c'est si tu peux être tentés de
le faire
mais ça c'est incroyable
ça peut ça peut il peut trouver on est
sur le top mondial on s'attend à des
choses incroyables de ses joueurs
après je m'inquiète pas trop a dit reza
même s'il perd il a au el demain à jouer
au blanc
ne t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer
bien se passer ne t'inquiète pas en vrai
le fait de jouer aux ailes aux blancs
pour ali reza demain ne m'enlève une
pression pour lui incroyable
invoqué tu peux pas rater howell en fait
c'est enfin gervais tse clutch totale
quoi
il sera taux sérique firoud
et je dirais pas les deux sont les deux
sont très bons après c'est si fabiano la
gagne c'est fabiano stratosphérique si
la tiens
je sais pas c'est dur à dire comme parti
a quand même pas mal d'erreurs des deux
côtés c'est plus à un combat magnifique
dans le
dire dans le rapport de force que sur la
partie en soi
pas comment dire mais c'est cesser plus
le combat qui est beau que le que les
coûts en eux-mêmes que le niveau de jeu
en lui-même
on a vu des vies voire beaucoup moins
spectaculaire de carl scène mais
beaucoup plus tueur j call ou même de
caruana au même de fuir ou déjà là on
est loin d'une précision chirurgicale et
on est dans un combat entre deux hommes
c'est complètement différent ça qui est
beau c'est le sait le combat c'est la
lutte d'ailleurs fabiano se retrouve mal
autant il n'est pas à l'aise avec notre
famille
il n'est pas à l'aise entre cette note
le fabi
mais là aussi c'est très logique le truc
c'est que aussi c'est le coup que tu
veux jouer
d3f 5 sata quand même envie de faire
mais bon faut voir tour 8 à 5 c'est ça
qui est important
pour pouvoir prendre b4 ça c'est pas
facile mais accueille des cartes ici
quand même en b 4 cavaliers prend f5
hayatou re en maths
ni coup tu dois faire des deux femmes et
enfin en fait c'est vraiment dû là c'est
vraiment le clic au hasard
ça peut très bien rentrer dans un truc
comme ça
du coup à 5 îles pas con
des trois à six
amel à tapas b prend assistant
reprend-il roi prendre enfin c'est trop
compliqué on a tellement de partout
6/4 one à gagnoa et c'est maxime avec
les blancs qui aura une balle de qualif
est là tu es là tu cliques là en vrai
c'est du clic au hasard là c'est soit tu
tombe dessus soit tu tombe pas en fait
là il faut le beau lui c'est là qu'il ya
vraiment une partie de réussite
évidemment il ya le calcul ya des forces
des joueurs et tout mais là dans des
positions aussi complexe et où
finalement tu vas une fois qu'il sera
rentré dans une variante tu vas trouver
par la force des choses là il ya un côté
bo lui quand même tu vas jouer deux fois
la même partie les mêmes joueurs ça va
pas faire le même résultat il envoie aux
6 c'était le coup le plus logique
ali reza qui va devoir répondre il n'a
pas beaucoup de temps
celui-là pas le luxe de réfléchir
alireza des plombes
c'est la prépa de caruana qu'il a mis à
mal il reste plus de trois coups encore
m on est proche de la fin
les mets qui a pas besoin de se mettre
la pression sur 6,1 suis pas sûr que
c'était le meilleur coup honnêtement il
y en avait partout mais là c'est le
stress est ce qu ali reza ces deux tours
et fuite père mais c'est même pas sûr
ils envoyaient des trois noms ils
envoyaient des 3 3 qu'il envoyait des
trois détroit je crois que ça va
et f5 qui par tempo voilà c'était sur
des trois cités calculé vf5 qui part
donc là le truc c'est que sur des deux
il y aurait vous prendrez deux tours
prend ses six cf 6 et 12 h puntos
inarrêtable une tour ne peut pas arrêter
deux pions sixième dont qui mena sont un
des deux est injouable des deux fous
prend des deux rois prend des deux tours
processus mais prend ses six f-16 et
dois-je punchs
c'est chaud 1 c'est bouillant
20 secondes pour ali reza il est stressé
ça sent qu'il n'a pas le coin bref c'est
là sa clique au hasard là ça clique
cavaliers des 4
j'ai l'impression que c'était le coup
aux attentions fou prend b4y menace tour
et un math
il a fait tomber le pion ouais ça c'est
interdit heureusement de fabiano et
classe je crois qu'il appuie avant de le
remettre mais on sent qu'ils seraient
sains
je sais pas j'ai pas vu en tout cas s'il
a fait tomber qui l'appuient avant de le
remettre c'était c'était interdit
mais non ça c'était le coup que j'avais
faut prendre b4 menace tourer il a
peut-être oublié il ya peu de temps
bk rien n'est fait les amis rien n'est
fait
il a appuyé avant annoncé complètement
interdit soit je vous dit alireza il
faut quand même qu'il progresse là
dessus ça d'infos il dégage un peu les
cameramans et tout ça quand ils le gène
et et des fois il fait des choses qui
sont très très incorrect appuyé sur la
pendule avec le pion tomber s'il a fait
là j'suis pas sûr je sais qu'il a eue
fait par le passé là j'ai pas vu le
moment fort et un replay et s'il a eu
fait c'est très incorrect
c'est un peu c'est une question de faire
payer d'éducation par rapport aux
adversaires c'est quand même important
aussi
un terrier repose à pia serait
normalement en fait si t'appuyer sur
l'horloge et que tu avais une pièce
tombée fabiano pourrait appeler l'
arbitre m du temps de pénalité et
séraphin bon c'est un peu compliqué je
sais pas quelle est la règle en vigueur
mais tu dois tu doit replacer les pièces
avant d'appuyer
cgc la nervosité s'est pas volontaire ou
quoi mais vu qu'il en demande beaucoup
aux personnes extérieures alireza il
faut il faut montrer l'exemple aussi de
son côté
ça va viendra avec l'âge il est jeune il
a 18 ans
mais les règles sont les règles
parce que clairement s'il te reste une
seconde tu le fais et puis ça me
maintient en vie quoi faire mon peu
importe
imprévu les a choisis qu'on a vu en
arménien à kooyong ouais c'est ça mais
bon et juste pour pour dire
il faudra il faudra progresser là dessus
c'est important
il a quitté soit vendu plus rapide kfc
ça se fait pas quoi
fabiano classe là dessus de rien dire
quand même il faut le souligner
il faut souligner fabiano classe voilà
on est on est on pousse ce joueur
français à fond à fond pour le français
aimerait quand même des trucs un peu
voilà limité que les adversaires
sont respectueux il faut aussi le
souligner
surtout vous m'aviez taclé hier
bon je pense que l'idée en fait si vous
dis séance est fou prend des cadres des
deux fous prend des deux rois prend et
tour c5 et ça ça se voit avec les blancs
tu peux pas être moins bien pas trois
pions pour la pièce et à des punto qui
sont près de dames
il vaut mieux honorer
phallique un club italien c'est
exactement ce qu'on fait c'est
exactement ce qu'on fait
exactement ce qu'ont fait justement de
se focaliser sur l'attitude très fair
play du joueur du joueur italien
écart lycées de après fou prend des 4ème
et fou prend bay 4-2 en fait hafsi sky
prend bkf ça a été plutôt chaud
des deux on va bouger la tour
est en vrai le problème c'est que tu te
fais punto fait quoi
et toi qu'elle ferait laisser passer ça
moi non moi non
je n'ai pas la classe de fabiano je
préfère l'annoncé je me suis trop fait
enfler sur des trucs comme ça ça me
saoule
donc moi non j'aurais pas laisser passer
du tout quand j'aurai arrêté là point du
jour a appelé l'arbitré
j'aurais insupportable
je préfère annoncer à sa dépend contre
qui
contre maxime j'aurais rien dit
et contrebas qui non plus contre un
ministre ou un président
ça ne dit rien mais j'assume que je
l'aurais fait contre 99 % des joueurs
sauf contre un pote en fait sinon
j'aurais fait
ja suivre un jeu dit on mais j'aurais
fait je suis un enfant et je me suis
fait enfler beaucoup de fois sur des
trucs comme ça avec des parties que j'ai
perdu après du coup ça me saoule et 20
et je suis un en forêt
c'est comme ça
on va voir ce que fabiano fil cinéma
l'autan lui aussi
donc
est ce qu'il va trouver le foot français
cas il est hyper logique faut prendre b4
c'est le coût que j'aurais joué tempo
après j'aurai pas eu le temps pour ces
cinq tempo non plus
c'est le 39e 40e là il va y avoir encore
deux coups derrière
il ya aussi ce qui est tentant om et m6
qui prend 2,6
fois que ce soit en temps m6
par vous attend le coup j'ai dit tempo
après j'avais pas vu tours b 1 mais bon
quand tu as tour b 1
je vois pas la plus value de le faire
dans cet ordre là en fait à peut-être
tour ces deux mais bon
je sais pas mais ça ça donne quand même
tellement envie tu te débarrasses des
deux pions et ok il faut voir tour ces
cinq mais bon avec le temps normalement
tu vois
je sais pas après maintenant qu'on sait
qu'à la turbine ces gagnants ou quoi
c'est difficile de juger puisque encore
tour 8 à vrai dire
j'en sais rien je sais pas ce que
j'aurais joué
sur cinq qui a laissé six tours 4
faites moi j'aurais été rentrés en
content de rentrer là dedans parce que
j'aurais su que je la perds plus mais
bon
je sais pas hors effet les a ni
en tout cas c'est très tendu
je trouve c'est plus logique de faire ça
comme ça mais après j'en sais rien
en fait je me serais pas dit que je peux
enfin je me serais dit que ce pion de
façon j'ai sacrifié le fou dessus et il
fait fondre en d4 est donc j'aurais fait
ça aussi fou prend et des deux fous
prend donc c'est son 39e quoi fabiano
est en fait il sait que après des deux
foetus et qui menacent matt que des deux
est forcément il va faire [ __ ] en d2
direct et en fait il va récupérer du
temps
et là il va récupérer le temps en fait
du coup il sait qu'en fait ils jouent le
40e et là il récupère 50 minutes
c'est pas s'il est gagnant ou pas mais
en fait il a bien pris son temps pour
être bien sûr parce qu'il sait qu'il a
il a terminé deux ait note
c'est dommage que ça récupère 50 nice
arrive à tuer toute toute la rippe en
fait on reprend des de jouer c'est le
40e
ça va récup le temps
wafa billet vert respectueux qui c'est
qui s'est pas levée 40e qui est resté
assis pour jouer son coup qui va envoyer
un tour c5
sa mère tu quand on pousse un peu mais
clairement assumé l'ordi là çà
et là ça va calculer ça peut te choque
encore un côté fabi
petit cube
petit local la pub à skis par
et elle est belle
et elle est belle la pub là
allez belle bell
elle est magnifique
à la plus magnifique après ce design
note moi aussi je prends un petit peu
souffler
dans la belle plus petits pas
fait quoi maxime maxime il a fait drôle
c'est plutôt un bon résultat à vrai dire
auquel quel moment incroyable la cadence
est vraiment c'est dommage un c c'est
pour être bien sûr que les échecs ne
soit jamais vraiment populaire moi on
est bien sûr il y aurait eu que 25
minutes ce serait classe mais là
cinquante une chacun
éminent ya pas de wind est une chaîne
vesle nul chez shirov howell a gagné
donc à qu'un gars en fait qui gagne il
ya des gars il ya qu'un gars à 5 qui
revient si sarkissian pour le moment
donc ça va
ça assez cool pour le moment les
résultats pour un pour max
ça tue vraiment la paix il faudrait ce
serait dommage que les échecs puis ça et
pas
ce serait quand même dommage
ce serait quand même très dommage
young et avec un meilleur des partages
comme ben on verra les départage de la
fin de la ronde les amis ne vous
[Musique]
ne vendez pas la peau de l'ours avant de
l'avoir tué on verra bien aller des
bleus départage ça peut tourner d'un
côté ou de l'autre
bref tu vas partir dans le tchat
on va voir ce que ça va je mens gros le
coût qui gagne sur ses seins en fait
c'est le couple logique la torah attaque
et on défend le pion
cette
cavale et f5 et canam et or c'est cette
c'est con ce que tour c'était mon coup
de base mais cavaliers f5 tu te fais
prendre h4 après tu te fais prendre g3
tu te fais tout prendre
donc à
tour f1 je fais un tour c5 venir ont eu
cinq en fait et coupé le roi aussi
le résultat quand même probable 80%
caroit et non 53 cents caruana 50% nul
je pense
quelle partie incroyable mais si fabiano
gagne
rien ne sera remis en cause un
show en vrai ça va être chaud
une petite descente qui descendrait pas
on peut pas rester
à 100% focus
on va attendre va laisser un petit peu
joué là on a un peu récupéré aussi c'est
un peu le temps mort du truc
même pas un peu beaucoup
on va on va récupérer un petit peu
a récupéré un peu quelles parties de fou
quand même
quelles parties de fou
parti vraiment incroyable quand on y
pense
partie vraiment de fous furieux
sur la f1 aussi si tu gagnes c'est un
problème
si tu gagnes c'est un vrai problème
énorme problème si tous gagnants vrai
père athir atteint
si tu gagnes c'est un peu la s
il a joué tout reste
trop logique tour ces cinq pour ne pas
de jouer et il se lève
ça va être terrible pour ali reza dans
la tête quand même de perdre cela il a
pris des risques un cavalier e 4 qu'il a
joué le 3 résultats
il a vraiment tout donné à lire raisin
pour la gagner
vraiment qu'il ait beaucoup de réussite
pour s'en sortir ici après il a la
baraka dans ce tournoi
si fabiano gagne c'est sûr que ça va
être une belle fabiano demain mais
maxime il va gagner
pas de pression et fabiano avec les
noirs c'est le péno pour maxime
j'ai tellement confiance en notre maxime
fabiano il n'est pas assez bon dans le
jeu contre maxime ils vont nous nous
dégoter une petite prépa pas piquée des
hannetons avec avec baky ça va jouer
fabiano il va craquer vous allez voir
vous allez voir
foule confiance en ministre et le
président
aucun aucun souci
en caruana on le bat et on est qualif
c'est tout
il va lui rendre la monnaie de sa pièce
des candidats de l'année dernière ça va
être très très bien en réalité
c'est très très bien ça va permettre de
remettre les pendules à l'heure et de
rappeler les bases
vincent sa mort ce soir si c'est pas sûr
qu'on puisse faire les vidéos avec fable
donc ce sera peut-être des régimes et
exprès
parce que ça j'ai pas le temps
d'analyser les parties à fond et fab est
occupée ce week-end donc normalement ce
soir on doit pouvoir encore en faire
ensemble si on termine avant 19 heures
mais demain ce sera moins seuls et ce
sera un
une analyse express pas le temps
alors on peur j'ai pas peur
peur
toujours fous confiance en le ministre
on a autre côté il y aura des joueurs
devant mais maxime avec une victoire ils
repassent devant tout le monde c'est
parfait
c'est parfait
après si on peut prendre aux ailes avec
les blancs on prend
en fait il va y avoir tout re 5 et puis
on va filer si vous dites +5 en fait ça
a pas l'air très urgent retour 8
apparemment rêve de important
et tours 5e set sf si cette
personne va gagner c'est sûr que c'est
gagnant ça
y'a même pas de doute en fait
fait tour 8es
[Musique]
bref deux semblent importants
on va voir ça risque d'être long un
parcours en revanche
et prendre 1 6 3 et puis on prend un
système c'est ça même si tu gagnes les
pions en fait le truc c'est que les
blancs sont en avance sur la poussée
donc
c'est terminé ça
même s'ils réussissent à les gagner en
fait les blancs ils sont trop proches de
l'âme
chiasson qu'elle se joue tout seul à
être le seul truc c'est qui dit quand
l'ordi les tours e5 qui avait laissé six
tours 4 roi des trois-rois f3 mais ça ça
doit gagner ici en fait
c'est terminé aussi ça apprendre les
pions va revenir en g5y on va gagner
ça ressemble vraiment tout gagné
sur une unique
les
usa bat donc une chaîne de télé marc m'a
proposé en même temps complexe
complexe
non une belle partie belle partie 1
terna reviendra quand tu atteins en plus
il a joué howell je crois il a un bon
départageant plus caruana
ouais après ali reza il faut surtout
s'il perd aujourd'hui qu'ils soient pas
vains qui reste dedans parce qu'il est
encore on est 1 du tournoi
même s'il perd il a encore en tête
à vrai dire il va être rejoint par ol
seulement et caruana
aussi par hbo lui il joue à l aube
lendemain
il suffit de battre ol en fait donc il
est très très bien
et ça chie quirion a gagné contre eliane
offs est excellente nouvelle aussi pour
le départage de max
et alireza
ça c'est un peu la bonne nouvelle qu'on
attendait pas aussi
c'est un peu la good news qu'on
attendait pas vierge qui a gagné aussi
sauf qu'ils arrêtent de perdre
presque qui a d'euros
ça c'est cool en vrai
sur anthony votants données différentiel
entre favy firo mv le reste des genres
balle et une énorme différence de niveau
le problème c'est que tu as une arme et
de plots qui jouent entre eux
donc
les meilleurs ils sont en tête après les
autres c'est une armée de plots qui
jouent entre eux qui mettent des points
tu fais jouer cent fois le tournoi où
elle il va être une ou deux fois dans le
top je vais 100 fois le tournoi nouvelle
fabia louis faraut farruggia ils seront
quarante fois à quoi
c'est les plots ils forment une pyramide
ils se battent entre eux et ça amène des
plots haut dans le classement quoi
donc en fait c'est un peu le tournoi qui
veut ça quoi
pour ça que toujours à la fin
homeaway lille a eu du bol dans masse de
partie contre nexans il était
complètement foutu il a sauvé on sait
pas comment contrer si bienne cas il
était complètement foutu ça s'est
retourné à la fin il a de la réussite
c'est tant mieux pour lui mais tu joues
100 fois le tournoi il va et va pas être
souvent heureux
c'est le format qui veut ça comme tu as
beaucoup de joueurs faibles qu'ils
jouent ensemble en a forcément un qui va
battre les autres et qui va sortir du
lot
c'est le format le plus aléatoire que tu
puisses avoir en fait
ça ajoute boucle le format suisse ajoute
beaucoup de
d'aléatoire ont les niveaux sont quand
même assez serré
en match il n'aurai aucune chance
d'ailleurs la coupe du monde
des joueurs de niveau 26 50 quand même
sorti à
un moment en fait ils font sortir par un
fort puisque sur
sur deux parties c'est dur même champ
clan du coi qui envoyait qui est bien
plus fort qu elle ça passe pas mon temps
et surtout cette année avec peu de top
player web
sur la f2 pourquoi qui les prend b3 ça
passe pas à me j'imagine que ça va vite
en fait
c'est toujours la même des objets de
sacrifier
ça c'est complètement foutu
ce que tu penses tu peut être qualifié
de prodige des échecs à 20 clairement
au nom des plombs ça arrive que oui mais
ça peut être des seconds ans qui sont
encore plus pro que croit parfois même
pas du tout non ils peuvent aussi jouer
seul
après ça change de temps où tu as les
mêmes 8 10 joueurs sympas aussi à moi
j'aime bien en fait le format est cool à
suivre mais à vrai dire ça va un
contresens de l'argument on veut que le
meilleur gagne aux échecs il faut faire
des parties bien longue pour être bien
sûr que les meilleurs soient devant et
derrière tu m'as un format où ça va pas
du tout être le cas donc c'est
complètement incohérent mais sinon il
c'est sympa à suivre
l'autre sens après je fais 536 pub ah
bah il faut qu'on renvoie un peu des
pubs là désolé mais du coup je suis en
retard sur les pubs vous en avez pas du
tout mis pendant le moment clutch du
coup obligé de rattraper ici
on
les pubs
soumis depuis un an qu'il fallait mettre
que par trois minutes
mais bon moi on a bien de la pub c'est
bien
rennes je vais être heureux
alem allumer la lumière et je vais aller
manger un truc je reviens
je vais en profiter
mega la petite pause qui a fait du bien
aubin s'est absolument rien passé as il
a joué tours 5
alors qu'ils étaient censés pas être le
meilleur coup d'un
seul à un petit peu mangé un petit peu
me faire un thé tout à vous
ouais ça je ressens un peu la fatigue
bas c'est vrai qu'on a eu un moment de
hype assez intense et du coup un bon je
suis quand même à
5h à 5h15 de stream sur la journée donc
ils m'ont donné en fait le truc est trop
trop d'émotions pendant trop longtemps
besoin de souffle à dos en fait un
surtout qu'on a un peu pour la position
maintenant c'est soit il trouve soit il
trouve pas à mais je pense il va trouver
comment dans la game sens est perdant
mais pas sûr à 100%
beaucoup de commentateurs main
pas de truc c'est que tu es là tu es
arrivé caractères ep et puis ça retombe
complètement quoi ca
pourrais faire des analogies quoi c'est
pas pas très agréable en fait
n'a pas trop l'habitude de ce genre de
chose quoi
ça monte ça monte ça monte puis ça
s'arrête quoi les échecs ses camarades
spéciale
et on sait très bien de quoi ça parle en
fait même pensé de quoi ça parle c'est
qu'en fait toutes les choses de notre
1 pour replacer la tour et on va prendre
les pions
pas sûr que ce soit si phoenix à ça
je pense qu'il ya encore des places à
gagner mais encore des possibilités à
mon avis
on a dix pas très agréable en effet ben
ouais en fait toutes les choses de notre
vie
tous nos loisirs et tous tous les
spectacles qu'on regarde sont pas faits
pour monter en intensité et complètement
baissé pendant longtemps c'est comme ça
à nana nature notre nature même fait que
ces choses on n'aime pas ces choses là
en fait
se rit de crescendo décrescendo ray
c'est ça mais en fait là ça fait
crescendo et puis ça s'arrête
complètement et tu dois attendre deux
heures pour avoir une mini crescendo de
nouveau
et ça en fait ça va pas du tout avec
avec la nature humaine en fait on n'est
pas fait pour ça
non mais c'est pas une bonne question
d'instantanéité fille axelle
les vieux films sont aussi fait comme ça
tout est fait comme ça en fait même les
villas et les anciennes pièces de
théâtre et tout ça tu as des actes qui
monte et à une résolution à la fin c'est
ta table à un truc qui se résout pas
quoi
le théâtre est
en gros tout toutes nos activités
loisirs artistiques sont fait comme ça
en fait
non en fait c'est ça c'était tellement
intense tellement intéressant et tout
mais après on tue mais on met une clim
pendant une heure et demie où il se
passe rien quoi c'est dommage
et en fait y'a plus rien à raconter la
cessoie ils trouvent soit il trouve pas
mais du coup ça ça ça peut pas
fonctionner en fait pour du public c'est
ça va à l'encontre même de notre nature
pointe rouge s'est pas exactement mais
qu'elle et ses six tours 4 j'ai
l'impression aura des trois-rois f3 ça a
l'air d'être gagnants
café roi f4 et f6
l'accord trouvé pour faire une chanson
qui a plus rien je pense que ces
perdants et qui a plus rien à trouver
mes cavaliers c'est si ça a l'air d'être
le coût qui est le plus relou
problème de raccourcir les temps c'est
connaître comme 40 gagne 8 ou du jouet
tempo ça prépare le problème de caruana
sa faiblesse c'est justement les
cadences rapides
les cadences rapides défavorise les
joueurs avec des grosses prépa
est justement caruana c'est un mauvais
blitzer et il est un peu moins bon en
cadence rapide
c'est ce que j non mais ça défavorise
les cadences rapides ou tamachek ça
allait le favoriser sa défavorise
caruana
concrètement peut-être pas ça va
dépendre
regardant au loin cedro l'évaluation de
leur dis car les pions
on serait quand même des extrémités
je pense pas mais bon
une force et un vrai droit d'être assis
je vous parlais
f27 qui avait laissé six tours des 5 4
et tu peux pas prendre live set donc il
prend 1,7
pour d un
roi f5 puis on prend 1,7 enfant un set
et ça il ya des mondes où c'est nul
ce genre de trucs bizarres peuvent être
nuls
lors des cinq croit g63 f3
des fois les trucs comme ça qu'ils sont
nuls
peut-être il l'a souvent
ils marient pas vous prenez pas du tout
ce que enfin
vous résumer un truc que j en cinq
minutes en une phrase donc je ne veux
pas répondre à ce truc là enfin c'est
pas tout à fait ce que j'ai dit mais bon
comme toujours on prend
ce que j'ai expliquées de manière
complexe ans en 5 minutes et on en fait
une phrase qui résume à un truc
compliqué qu'il résume pas bien donc
sophisme et drainant et c'est terrible
ça sent la fumée chez moi vérifiez pas
quelque chose qui brûle
ça semblait en plein
temps et les gars c'est pas de moi
ah non ça vient de l'extérieur
ça vient de l'extérieur
ça sans bois brûlé
ça sent le bois brûlé en fait
non mais quand il n'y a pas de fumée ya
que l'odeur c'est comme s'ils avaient un
feu de forêt un peu loin entre comme ça
ascenseur de cheminée près de chez moi
mais ouais ça pourrait être ce genre
d'odeurs plus tôt
sinon à détroit ouais ok faut jouer g4
au bon moment pour faire âgées est monté
le roi dans le bon tempo
ça se peut qu'ils se peut qu'ils
trouvent pas vrai
ça peut tenir encore pour ali reza
avec la 3 bouteilles déjà ils ont ramené
une quatrième terrible
pas du tout dit ça trop god
oh non j'en ai marre des gens qui
j'ai pas besoin de ventriloque frérot un
pour dire ce que j'ai à dire
il y aura des trois c'est peut être le
coup et
dont deux fils de drogue
ça aide surtout ban the troll
avoir déjà balancé une simulation à
plein de choses possibles à faire là ya
autant de coups possibilités mais on
sent que les blancs vont avancer après
je pense était moins précis le roi f-22
l'ordi semble plus direct en fait
j'aurais bien ta place est parfois je
suis quand même content de pas me taper
tous les cours du château
c'était que les couillons du tchad
frérot ça irait mais ça continue après
en fait
ça qu'il n'a pas beaucoup d'eau autour
de lui important de boire
ouais il cherche et cherche ali reza
je sais pas quoi vous dire en fait là on
attend
on attend un ferrer ce contrôle du temps
c'est vraiment un 1 tu joie
c'est un tueur joie
tration c'est très dur ce qu'ils sont en
train de réaliser mais en fait là quand
tu regarde y'a plus qu'à attendre quand
il met 25 me pour bouger un pion en bout
de bois
c'est un peu too much
un véritable tueur du reste un crémant
mal si tu voulais faire en sorte que les
échecs devienne jamais populaire tu
ferais pas autrement en fait
c'est terrible
pour nous du candidat quand il commet à
sa déjà on sait pas qu à mindanao
évidemment c'est pas quand ça aura lieu
une ue parce que ce serait trop dur de
prévenir 6 mois al avance
c'est un mois jour en cadence rapide
mais s'ils veulent jouer en cadence
longue ne rajoutez pas plus de 25
minutes en fait au 40e
après qu'un incident et à l'idéal c'est
le rapide 25 + 10 ou 15 plus disent
quelque chose là dedans mais dans les
cadences yong il faut jamais rajouter 50
et plus encore 15 au 60e
pour moi les gars ensemble sa tradition
la précision enfin là avec les 50
minutes de plus ce taux augmente par la
précision j'ai faim excuse moi de te le
dire mais
les 58 rajouter la mise à part niro
spectacle elles font pas grand chose au
bout d'un moment il ya une limite autant
que tu as fascine on pourrait dire oui
je vais te redonner une dizaine d'heures
pour être bien sûr enfin juste là le
temps que tu rajoutes
ça change quasiment rien la précision
des femmes parties en fait
bon alors si non pourquoi mettre aussi
peu de temps pour mettre beaucoup plus
j'aurai forcément un tout petit peu
mieux non oh bah tu regardes temps vu la
partie de nayer c'était terrible
la partie de navarra ya deux jours
c'était pareil ça joue assez mal après
le 40e globalement parce que les joueurs
sont fatigués donc en fait
le fait que tu sois fatigué fait que tu
calcules moins bien
mais disons que quand on avait eu 25
minutes à la coupe du monde savait pas
nui aux cayes la qualité des parties
mais ça avait largement améliorer le
spectacle il ya un moment il faut quand
même faire des concessions quoi
les 25 minutes elles permettent en fatwa
une continuité dans la partie et que les
joueurs récupèrent un peu de temps pour
bien finir et c'est pas fait pour faire
durer le tueur est le truc deux fois
plus longtemps quand il reste quatre
pièces quoi
la 10 il ya un juste milieu à trouver
dans ce coin valeurs bon je pense qu'en
tennis sur la chaîne il est plutôt pour
les cadences rapides à maxime parce que
plus pour le spectacle et les échecs
doivent rester un divertissement un
loisir après je n'aime pas trop parler
pour quelqu'un d'autre c'est pour maxime
sait qu'il aime bien les rapides après
les longues ça peut c'est bien aussi
mais bon là le 50 minutes fait mal à
tout le monde
pas miser sur un
mail à 25 minutes il va être papa tout
miser sur un blender en fait enfin puis
à un moment donné le blender enfin faire
une erreur ça vient aussi de ça fait
partie du jeu coiffard là il y en a eu
des erreurs dans cette partie l onf a
été éliminé donc au bout d'un moment
il ya un juste milieu à tout
tant est que tu joues tu l'utilisés
honnêtement pour acheter souvent mal
autant en langues
j'utilisais le temps que j'avais
parti qui peut laisser des traces à un
feu rouge à
mentalement physiquement
car en effet quoi ouais il est parti des
fois il ya des salles de repos ils
peuvent s'allonger même sur des canapés
ou quoi parfois avec une salle avec des
boissons les genres tu te barres tu
t'assieds autre part tu
perds un peu l'esprit à ce moment de la
partie
les deux dernières au blanc c'est
possible mais il ya un monde
quand ils se savent qu'un jour et jouer
dans la salle de repos à des fois ils
font des petits aller-retour pour cech
de quel côté la pendule et appuyer
les consciences hyper fil rouge avec
caen il a s'éloigne au il restera au
coude à coude il faudra faire une grosse
fin de tournoi mais reste en piste un il
serait premier ex-aequo rhin
on le droit de voir une bière et je
crois qu'on a plus droit de boire
d'alcool devant les parties
tu peux parler que de joueurs en salle
de repos n'ont normalement tu as le
droit de parler avec personne sauf avec
l' arbitre c'est à quelque chose à
demander
qui semble à sa détente et sa partie non
et c'est déjà arrivé que des arbitres
réveil des joueurs dans la salle de
repos de détente
alors à l'écouté de la musique non t'as
pas le droit d'avoir d'appareils
électroniques sur toi
là tu buvais pendant les parties ouais
ça a pu arriver
la gare arbitres non non je dois lui
dire que des
on écran que j'ai mon ordinateur qui
allait passer en mode veille terrible
même l'ordi s'endort
là
le droit de jouer s'ils sont sous
médicament
concentration à sa folie relais liste
des cachets considérés comme des dopants
précisons une ordonnance et amis avoir
le droit il faut une ordonnance soit
sous ordonnance tu peux way lorsque des
antihistaminiques ou quoi il vaut mieux
une ordonnance
un jour le droit de prendre
ça tu peux pas évidemment
kemmer poufy route je sais pas des gens
dans le chat qu'on y croie détroit était
plus piégeurs d'hôtes ont parlé de
carolis et 6
tout doit pas aller mais il faut
regarder avec l'ordi ce qui donne le
plus de chance là nous on n'est pas là
pour ça
le niveau des arbitres en moyenne où ils
sont pas très forts généralement face à
des pans des compétitions ça peut
dépendre de beaucoup de choses
il a joué quoi
elle joue un coup droit non derrière la
bouteille
voyait fabiano ils n'étaient pas loin il
a joué roi des trois c'était peut-être
le coup de pub piégeur
est ce qu'on nous a pas annoncé que
c'était le coup le plus piégeurs tout à
l'heure à
eux sept cavaliers c6
tour des 5 3 4 f6 cavale et prendre sept
tours d un an et cette variante que vous
avez tout à l'heure et on nous a dit que
ça s'était pas
c'était pas clair
ok du coup le redis propose roi f2 tout
recette pour gagner et g4 à geroy g3
mais ça il va jamais trouvé
donc il sait peut-être planté fabi c'est
peut-être planté en fait il a peut-être
mal joué peut-être son tour cinq étaient
mal joué
son tour eu cinq étaient peut-être mal
joué
et si tu fais g4 direct à j'ai froid
j'ai trois
cavaliers f3
qu'est la différence c'est quand tu fais
rêve de tour 7 g4 qui on prend roigé
trois cavaliers f3
tf6 tu touches la tour et tu gagnes ok
vas jamais trouvé
césar va tu rajoutes 50 minutes de toute
façon ils peuvent pas trouver la
meilleure ligne
donc en fait fait faute sur faute en
fait 3 prend des deux sets gagnants tour
c5 tourer 8 fait dès qu'il a réfléchi la
fée fauteurs fabi
et aux cinq essais 6 tours des cinq
croit ici aussi ça qui prend 1,7
tordères
et puis on prend 1 7% et ça ça doit être
nul
ça peut être nul c'est pas sûr que ça le
soit tour des six tours troyes tours h6
non ça doit être perdant quand même roy
g4g 6 3 et 5 tours g53 f6 tourage cinq
tours b 3
passes et perdant je suis quasiment sûr
ça ira mais est ce que c'est vraiment
gagnant à izmir
tu pas sûr que ce soit gagnant ça
art et ça c'est gagnant
puis dans le carré ça c'est complètement
gagnant c'est incroyable ordi donne plus
deux comme il exactement constant dit ok
alors dit comprenait pas que ces
gagnants
donc ça ça agl de gagnant en fait
qu'elle juste l'ordi comprend pas mais
c'est gagnant lors d'y évalue mal
mais ça c'est gagnant
ça c'est gagnant ça il peut trouver
je suis dans le carré et à sa gagner tu
peux rien faire en fait
et après tu envoies
les très linéaire c'est eux cette crise
et six tours des cinq roccat f6 menaçait
vii qui éprouvent cette force et c'est
tour d un qui est un peu dure à trouver
pour tourer roi f5 force et puis on
prend tout reprend tour des 6es tourache
si ça c'est fini du coup tu dois
sûrement faire tourage 7 mai à ça c'est
une gueule de gagnant pour les blancs
ça c'est gagnant je pense pour les
blancs
le roi va monter tours h6 prendrait les
pions sont en avance il a fait roi f2
bon je sais pas s'il a vu le g4
mello de gagner aussi apparemment bah en
fait le problème c'est que vous m'aviez
dit à deux coups gagnants et j'espérais
que en fait les deux seuls coupe tu as
envie de jouer ce héros f2 ou 7 ses deux
coupe tu as envie de faire donc cette
avait l'art de gagner roi abdallah ii
gagne aussi en vrai dire
quand j'arrive dans le problème c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de faux voire en fait à
quel moment il peut se tromper famille
si un moment où il peut se tromper
peut-être plus qu il est vrai mais en
fait les deux directions gagne
je vous fais du bruit fait bouger la
table avec ses pieds de marc ways ce que
je disais je trouve que fuir ou en fait
il est très exigeant sur le comportement
des autres
mais son comportement au niveau de ne
pas faire de bruit pour pas déranger
l'adversaire c'est pas top top quoi
c'est pour ça qu'ils hier quand quand il
y avait un problème avec une caméra je
disais fait tomber les pions il fait pas
mal de trucs qui sont qui dérange les
joueurs adverses et il est très exigeant
envers les autres
pour ça que c'est pour ça que j'ai dit
hier quand il fait bouger la caméra
machin il n'est pas le mieux placé pour
le faire après tout ce qui me tombe
dessus sur le tchad ouais machin c'est
normal ouais
nettoie déjà devant ta porte et après on
verra la porte des autres quoi
ça sur ce jeu non mais c'est des rangs à
voir des gens comme ça qui bouge
beaucoup leurs pieds tout c'est un peu
dérangeant après tout le monde s'emballe
avec un soyons d'accord
le fait de faire tomber le pion quoi de
ta l'heure c'est pas c'est pas terrible
non plus après c'est pas des choses
graves mais juste ok si tu fais faut pas
reprocher aux autres de faire
mais bon il a 18 ans machin tous étaient
insupportables étant à dos 1
on a tous été insupportable étant ado il
n'y a pas de raz-de-marée puis bon ça
dérange pas vraiment fabiano je peux
vous le dire on s'en fout complètement
fabiano je vous rassure
je vous rassure
fabiano ça ne le dérange pas d'un iota
c'est pas ça qui va qui va déstabiliser
le joueur américain
si je vous ai dit mais je commenterai
pas je vous ai dit hier mais je pense
pas que voulait dit aujourd'hui je
commenterai un
un tournoi pour les étudiants
je vais vous envoyer en twitter comme ça
vous pouvez tchèque jeu juste envoyé le
lien dans le chat et du coup aussi vous
souhaitez participer n'hésitez pas à
cech c'est sympa ça organisé par société
générale ea sports
et
et c'est un tournoi pour les étudiants
ça a l'air d'être un des tracés sympa je
vais remettre le lien twitter pour ceux
qui n'ont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas vu le truc j'en profite
des gens qui veulent qui veulent
participer ça va être un petit un petit
tournant est cool
mr souveraine us way
c'était sympa garage était sympa jusqu'à
jusqu'à jusqu'à 15 16 ans femme de
fabrice après ça m'a saoulé d'être
gentil
mais oui j'ai été très gentil très
longtemps je me suis fait qu'anne plein
de fois après j'ai un peu arrêté
un coup fumant et je suis plein de fois
financer les tournois mécénat la plupart
du temps ou argent public tu la plupart
du temps argent public tahir ça fait
quoi toujours nos amis et ouais argent
public ou mécénat ce qui peut en quelque
sorte être la même chose
on a vu le problème sur tour ici c'est
qu'il va y avoir j'ai quatre options
prend roi monté le roi va monter va
aider les pions et se termine à 2 1
ouais plus dix minutes pour ali reza
essentielle parce qu'il regarde les
gagne des autres trop longtemps où on
dérange ceux qui jouent non non
ouais là là il a fait mal caruana le
rêve de bien jouer
et fable sa famille s'entend assez bien
avec maximum après maxime s'entend bien
avec tout le monde
mais tous réfutent et horrifique je
pense yves eu cinq noms
d'objets de revenir en 8es f6
pour la vidéo et kakashi fresque de
mettre des chronos pour bien montrer la
tension dans les couvrait as-tu fait le
montage du coup frérot et tu retrouves
les chronos exact
tu
fais ça pourquoi pas un qui a joué tours
surtout sur une analyse ça absolument à
rien ou quasiment mai
le faire j'ai quatre enragé 3
il va il va faire du coup
il va rentrer dans salal douadi amiante
la tour vient f3 elle couvrait le pion à
vence ça ressemble d'ailleurs à fuir ou
china hier en fait dans l'esprit
terrible
précise pour le coup prend du temps
quand il sait chanter à vendre oui c'est
toujours précises avec madjid zaïm matin
si vous écoutez les vidéos vous le savez
en fait
quand on a vu les
quand on a vu les photos écouté les
commentaires on sait qu'on a vu les
parties en direct je le dis souvent
mais non ça faisait 4 puis on prend aux
ag 3 et il va monter
je pensais vraiment qu'il allait partir
pour le set qui me paraissait plus
linéaire personnellement mais bon
ils sont forts ils sont très forts
carney 2ème finito ou pas du tout maxime
va voir les blancs d'oeufs de lait blanc
demain c'est loin d'être fini tôt 1
bref si je gagnais pas j'imagine qu'ils
assisteront aussi c'est assez chiant
non pas voir firoud howell et mvl
caruana way et du coup firoud en battant
ouali se qualifie quasiment en fait donc
fillon ouvre il est bien dans le coup
malgré une défaite aujourd'hui qui n'est
pas encore arrivé ils restent favoris
quand même
c'est quand même à noter quoi
il reste quand même favori du tournoi
alireza malgré
même si une défaite arrive ici scié par
il n'a pas encore perdu mais même en
perdant aujourd'hui reste encore favori
du tournoi donc ça va il n'y a pas péril
en la demeure
je vais aller tchèque 6 à d'autres
résultats
moyens manuels petrossian juste pour
voir contre max ou de luz
et vouloir opposer ces bonnes nouvelles
ça à part monter et m.chen quo
serait bien qu'ils tiennent pour le
départage de maxime
donc non ça va
actuellement ça va ya pas trop de gars
qui ont gagné et il y aura que oh well
as his ennemis si fabiano gagnent ils
seront 3 6 ennemis maximal 6 dans un
groupe assez confidentielle assez
restreint en plus y aura encore sa
chique yankee un pas et les remarques sa
cheville en simple aux absolue quand
même
attention à junghee
peut-être est-ce qu'il y avait un bond
et partage you
il avait un bon départage ne s'est pas
dit qu'ils en un meilleur que maxime ce
qu'il a joués firoud qui a peur
howell en départage vraiment pour av
confiant
la wind de youyous il était derrière
nous ils avaient moins de points de base
soit 100 faudra gagner demain y
réfléchir après on a envie de te dire ça
rien de regarder le classement
on va voir une entrée l'avait pas le g4
tempo rives de tours sète y avait pas le
chèque quattro ce pas sûr qu'ils la
gagnent un fab y aller on espère encore
un peu le g4 fait mal en revanche le g4
fait mal mais il n'est pas encore parti
et encore un peu un tout petit peu
d'espoir
des 4 au 6 mai 14e bekkat c'est un peu
con quoi
fait le truc de cet été entre guillemets
plus facile si t'as pas chez quatre
maintenant
on verra en tout cas faut que maxime
gagnon ya trop de gens coller au même
score faut que maxime gagne au blanc
demain et on verra après
il a jugé qu'à un bien joué je pensais
pas qu'il aurait
après façon s'il avait pas le g4 il
aurait eu deux tours 7
très bien joué de la part de fabi
sa clique côté fabi
leila cliquer
là il a cliqué de ouf
puis on prendra jettera et nan ça fait
mal
ça fait très très mal alireza en
finalement c'est peut-être le roi de 4
quand il est parti au charbon là
c'est peut-être là dessus qu'il a perdu
finalement
quand il est parti jouer pour trois
résultats
il a peut-être été trop gourmand alireza
il s'est senti pousser des ailes
il s'est senti pousser des ailes et il a
voulu prendre fabiano encontre qui a été
exceptionnel aujourd'hui fabiano
qui va reprendre reprendre de l'écart au
classement elo ainsi la victoire se
confirme alors qu'il n'était pas loin de
passer numéro quatre mondial
va reprendre un petit écart sur ali reza
mais à ce n'est que partie remise
en fait il est en désaccord depuis
longtemps il a un peu perdu en lucidité
il s'est dit qu'il allait le battre en
contraire et ça fait tourner la partie
en faveur de fabiano qui est restée
calme malgré son raté
fabien les raisins sont les deux
premiers exactement
c'est exactement ça
trois projets 4
et maintenant les pions vont avancer le
roi est venu protéger f5 et ça va faire
recette et si m6 à vii
en y aura cru les amis aujourd'hui
on ya cru aujourd'hui
on a vibré
mais ça ne suffira probablement pas
ça y est les deux pions sont trop fort
ça soit les raisins à l'air résigné
c'est trop facile à présent
c'est trop facile il va jouer quelques
coups par inertie et abandonné
désillusion côté français mais alireza
aura aura tout donné et il faut pas se
désunir il est encore leader du tournoi
à la suite de cette partie donc c'est
pas le moment de
de niaiser j'ai envie de dire
terrible
à fêter ses 6
voilà le plus drôle c'est que le cou qui
gagnent le plus clean c'est le plus
simple en fait c'est roy f4
et josh bernoff
loge puntos
gens voyaient un petit tweet
envoyé un petit tweet
qui peut carrie à tout moment mais là je
pense pas
ouais 4 est le coup le plus simple est
vrai bien il tentera peut-être tourache
pour des 5,3 bourges m6 en
se défaisant jeu plus max que jaja
pas forcément parce que du coup j'arrive
à jouer à l'ol et lui offre si vous
ouvrez lui offrira pas deux nuls donc
mécaniquement il rattrapera
et du coup pas bien à nos 6 maxime le
joue au blanc
le coup le plus fin à vrai dire
c'est quand même hallucinant la part de
chance qu'il faut fonction well as est
tombé sur ol demain avec les blancs
c'est vraiment vraiment pas mal
faudrait pas obligé de prendre la tour
ouais mais tu prends plus à tous par la
tour au prochain tf6 en fait je la
défends du goût
le problème c'est que bref 4 du coup il
ya eu six au prochain
tour le commentaire cash sectionné ben
écoute merci hein t'as kiffé n'hésite
pas à 7 sur ma chaîne envie de dire
héros qui se fait sa pub
on fait ce qu'on peut pour faire kiffer
les échecs 1
ohler safway
mais la wii
par
jeu rien à faire
pierrot jackys en tête peut-être un peu
trop
aléatoire en 2010 tournoi qu'il faut se
battre une défaite aujourd'hui c'est ça
on voit aussi pourquoi habituellement
ces tournois sont entre joueurs du top
niveau ça évite un peu le côté loterie
de battre les plots quoi qu'ils peuvent
sortir des bonnes game des mauvaises tu
sais pas trop là la game les deux ont
sorti une top game 1 les deux ont bien
joué 1 c c'est fabiano qui sort qui sort
vainqueur mais les deux ont fait une
belle partie
et franchement heureusement qu'on a eu
les caméras c'est un sacrifice que
que je fais pour les avoir mais
franchement ça vaut le coup 1
franchement ça vaut le coup de les avoir
sur une partie autant les autres jours
on n'a pas franchement les caméras les
jours précédents les oreilles ou pas ça
change est quasiment air autant
aujourd'hui franchement elles ont
carrément
franchement aujourd'hui les cas mais
l'on carrie de ouf
il est aujourd'hui les fallait
aujourd'hui les fallait franchement je
regrette pas
regrette pas je sais pas si elles seront
utiles les jours d'après ou pas on verra
ça dépend des partis ça dépend de
beaucoup de facteurs d'aujourd'hui elles
ont qu'arrive
la wef au plus entêté il va falloir être
fort dans la tête devant quand même pour
firoud déjà encaissé la défaite
si changeantes n'ont pas présenté va
dire mais du coup je peux pas stream sur
ma chaîne
du coup ça ça m'enlève une certaine reip
et où c'est mon métier tu vois
ça c'est comme ça mais c'est pas grave
les infos qu'ils aillent faut qu'il
aille se reposer vous avez raison
faut plus grillé d'énergie sur celle là
j'aimerais savoir ce que pense fabi en
ce moment
il doit être content je pense il doit se
dire il doit dire vous m'avez enterré
trop tôt je suis de retour
je fais les analyses faites fable soir
voilà on va aller faire ce soir demain
je crois que fabi peut pas donc je me
débrouillerai
demain c'est quoi le match on sait pas
les caméras sur ma chaîne rai c'est
impossible c'est réellement impossible
est-ce que tu voyais femme
que tu payes fait partie sur ta chaîne
c'est déjà ça te regarde pas mais à ton
avis fois il suffit juste de réfléchir
un
ca vous trouve bien des poires les
caméras ou quoi je suis pas plusieurs
centaines millions d'euros par an c'est
dur
c'est quand vaille que vaille qu'ils
avaient accepté de les donner c'est le
seul tournoi en fait qui acceptait de
les donner
à titre gratuit
cible
était cool
termine à dos
s'est impatienté fier robin peut-être
abandonné c'est un peu trop senti
pousser des ailes fabiano était gagnant
il rate le gain alireza revient dans la
partie et il a peut-être
eu le vertige de trop de succès comme
disent les russes et à il a trop poussé
quoi
mais là y'a rien à faire un les pions
poussé
fait quoi ils tentent
dernière loterie cavaliers 7f si c'est
le cas et j'ai 6 bref cinq cars et les
âges
4,3 g 4 kg 6
tours 1 et essayer de lutter encore un
peu
well as raison de compte un petit peu
moi j'ai cinq si on doit passer aussi au
roi des 4
5 6
la raison de jouer à fond alireza la
pensée faut abandonner il ya une demi
heure soit continuer à la jouer
maintenant à deux façons 1
ce bail donne tout jusqu'au bout et a
et il tente et ils tentent d'aller
d'aller chercher le point quoi
le demi point plutôt
y arrivera sûrement pas mais bon
fait durer le suspense en face on lui a
filé 50 minutes c'est c'est bien pour
faire durer la partie
5 3 des 4
tours f8 il veut peut-être
à moi perso j'aurais fait f 6 kg 6 3 f 5
cavale est ici roi g4
qui a rédigé six tourer moi j'aurais
fait comme ça
ça paraît terminer un
merci surtout reif 8 à vii du coup kg 6
3 f
5,6 à paraître le plus direct
plus le plus direct le plus logique
tout cas visuellement
c'est ce que j'aurais probablement
choisi à titre perso
l'écossais après françois vous pas
vraiment maxim's par mauvais résultats 1
il n'y a pas eu tant de victoires que ça
à côté donc non pas la fin ouais
mauvaise journée parce que parce que je
suis roi perdue mais si maxime avait
perdu aussi s'arrêter journée cauchemar
c'est une mauvaise journée c'est la
première depuis une semaine
la nul hier de maxime était pas terrible
ça c'est vrai mais aujourd'hui non ça va
une dernière pub
la dernière de la journée
sa paire le vendredi il faut finir et
être un week end à ce week-end on va
faire mal
si vous glissez machine toi super
aléatoire et oui
c'est très aléatoire
le spectateur comme nous et fabiano qui
hésitent
fabiano qui hésite
les pubs qui partent
les pubs qui partent j'ai tout à l'heure
mais je redis merci encore pour la
patience des explications je file une
bonne soirée bonne soirée à toi
f si je crois
il a juste vérifier
et g63 f5
g6 qui prend h4
sûrement faire roigé
5000 amis ou leurs à
l'entourage et 5e 3 f 4
h 4 et 7
je veux une poche
le sprint of
love queen of qui font le taf
mes chers amis
ton conseil
prenne tout son sens c'est encore à
l'épinoche qui gagne
résister tout jouer tempo il en a marre
fabien en a marre que ça traîne
il veut pas lui laisser récupérer 25
minutes au 60e pour repartir
dans une demi heure de combat
rezaï a pas l'habitude d'abandonner un
c'est les jeunes ils abandonnent moins
que
que les vieux j'ai envie de dire
qu'elles étaient quatre
y avoir sept ans
ces jouets
j'ai pas trop compris le bail / f 7 à
vrai dire
aïe le tour sept
tours 37 quel point cette r8 dames et
cavaliers g6 mais à vrai dire même ça ça
marcherait paillard wager 5
terrible il va jusqu'au bout
non il va pas abandonner en fait il a le
sommes il devrait peut-être aller
en guérande avec
avec sa robe pour aller visiter les
marais salants
ça peut à mon avis partir sur une visite
des marais salants avec sarde
à tout moment il a fait tourner cinq
hafid dames
et ça y est ça abandonne
ça rigole maintenant un petit peu
à ça va
alors il est salam sall et il est salée
ça allait il était sale et alireza bon
ça faisait un moment qu'on s'y attendait
là ça faisait depuis une heure qu'on
savait que la partie était perdue
mais non ça va il a bien pris sa défaite
ça soit il discute avec favy ya quelque
chose qu'il a dû rater quelque part
j'ai su que fou prend b4 possible je
sais pas
bon faudra gagner demain avec les blancs
ça va il a pas l'air d'être trop
atteints psychologiquement ils avaient
la chance d'avoir un point d'avancé sur
la concurrence il va avoir un super
départage alireza
caruana qui l'emportent
et qui donc
revient en tête du tournoi avec david
howell iii âmes en tête alireza fuir ou
dja et fabiano caruana pour le départage
je ne sais pas ça doit être serré je
pense qu ali reza un tout petit mais
tout petit peu un meilleur des partages
que lui mais à vérifier et david howell
donc qui est derrière au départage donc
ces trois hommes sont devant suivi d'un
groupe avec mvl vite yougov schirrhoffen
weir aarau il ya du monde maxime il aura
probablement les blancs demain on espère
peut-être contre david howell on
n'espère pas contre fabiano même si en
battant fabiano il se met très très très
bien et c'est un adversaire plus facile
à david
comprend on l'espère sera de 2 français
1 qui freine la vidéo elle
car on a tout juste devant un corps
anaky qui repasse peut-être devant lui
pour repasser derrière par là les
départage c'est beaucoup trop c'est
beaucoup trop serré
donc sur un peuple fier et qui sont à
peu près ex-aequo alireza et et
[Musique]
fabiano et wayne avait quand même
beaucoup d beaucoup de points de
départage de retard donc lui il ne
refera pas le son retard mais voilà deux
hommes
deux amants tête égalité on va dire
et maxime derrière dans un groupe en
embuscade il faudra il faudra battre
l'armée des plots il faudra faire encore
moins un point et demi pour maxime un
point peut suffire pour fuir ou caruana
ça va dépendre aussi des résultats au
tour mais ça nous promet une fin de
tournoi haletante donc on se retrouvera
dès demain à 13 heures pour suivre le
sprint final je vous remercie encore
d'avoir suivi ce live en ma compagnie
c'était un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce divertissement et on se
retrouvera demain pour la suite des
événements je souhaite à tous une
excellente soirée je vous dis à demain
[Musique]